Hello everybody!
So like, there was not really a reason for me to loop.
I was like, ready and everything.
I just wanted, I just wanted my coffee to kick in.
I just, I just wanted my coffee to kick in.
So I was just like, you know what?
We're just gonna loop a little bit.
Uh, I took a, um, okay, so like, uh, by the way, I haven't had my sound, the acoustic whatever shit installed yet.
Um, because I'm still waiting from Amazon.
I don't know, I think it, let me check if it's delivered already.
Uh, cause I did have to walk dad, uh, I did have to walk dad a little earlier, so like, I need to check that.
Let me double check if it's here.
I was, I was gonna check it.
I was gonna check it earlier, but then I was like, eh.
I was like, eh.
Oh shit!
Okay, nevermind, it has arrived.
Okay, I'll pick it up.
I'll pick it up like, uh, after this stream.
Um, I'm just tired.
I'm just tired.
Um, so yeah, uh, fuck, what was it?
Oh yes!
World update.
There's no, like, personal news update because really there's nothing to update you about what's going on right now to me because I'm still, I'm still unpacked.
Are you okay?
No.
Like I said, I'm waiting for the coffee to kick in.
I was like, it was like, um, I like ate, uh, dinner.
I ate, like, dinner at, uh, mmm, at 3pm because I was like, oh man.
I don't want to eat dinner after the stream.
I'll just eat dinner now.
And then, you know, after you eat dinner, like your quote unquote dinner.
Um, it's because I ate breakfast and usually I don't eat breakfast, but like I woke up early today and ate breakfast at like, uh, 10am.
So then I was like, alright, I'm going to eat dinner at 3.
Um, and then, you know, I was like, should I, should I like be productive and do work?
Or take a one hour nap?
And as you all know, um, I think you can guess which one I chose.
So, so I decided to take that one hour nap because it looked so appetizing.
I was like, ah, clearly, you know, a one hour nap is not going to fuck me over mentally.
I'm not going to feel like I want to, I'm not going to feel like that.
I want to die inside.
So like, you know, not like I'll be like this time, this nap will be different.
This nap will be so different.
I'll feel so much energy and I will.
I have so much energy after the nap and I'll feel so restful and I'll be so fucking ready.
And yeah, so I was not ready.
I was, I was not ready.
Um, but yes, I, my brain is still, the cog wheels are still turning very slow right now.
So, um, I don't know how words work anymore right at the moment.
And I'm like, I can't really form sentences at the moment.
Um, but yes, if, if like you have something important to do.
And you're like, do I take a nap?
You do not take the nap.
Do not nap.
I don't know.
I keep telling you guys this, but I never listened to myself.
Like the amount of times I'll be like, don't worry guys.
I'll never take a nap before stream again.
And I still do it.
It doesn't...
I, why do I still do it?
Doki, this time, this time will be different.
Doki, this time you won't take that nap before your stream.
It doesn't matter.
You literally have one hour before your stream, Doki.
Don't you fucking dare.
But like, I never learned.
I'll be like, no, no.
This nap will be different.
Doki, you don't understand.
This is the one day that like your brain is suddenly gonna like rewire itself.
And you're gonna have like the perfect REM sleep schedule.
Where you're gonna wake up at the exact cycle of your REM sleep.
Where like you'll feel so much energy.
Uh...
So it's up.
I'll be like, this time it'll be different.
Anyway.
World update.
Cause I wanna talk about world news.
As in like Twitter news.
Um, did you guys see...
Did you guys...
Okay, you guys all know about like the strip, the break dancing shit in the Olympics, right?
I just, I saw this on my timeline today.
So like...
You guys all know about like the infamous...
Did you know break dancing was only for...
Was only brought into Olympics like this year?
That's so fucked.
And because of what Australia did...
It's not gonna be next...
It's not gonna be in next Olympics.
It's so...
It's so fucked.
It's really the first time break dancing was ever in the Olympics.
And because of Australia...
Because of Australia...
They were like, nevermind.
We are gonna remove break dancing from the Olympics.
And then it got so bad.
It got so bad.
There's a criminal...
There's an...
There's an actual criminal investigation right now.
Cause they were like, how the fuck did this person qualify into the Olympics?
Cause you know, all the countries gotta qualify first.
Before they get into the Olympic, Olympic broadcast part.
Cause the qualifications usually are not...
Usually are not like on TV.
And then...
So right now at the moment, there's an actual criminal investigation on her.
And her coach for like allowing them in.
Cause like somebody was like, this is her...
Somebody like showed a video of who it could have been to represent...
To represent Australia.
Cause like her rival...
They showed like a video of her rival.
Like that was supposed to...
That was like...
That was facing her to qualify into the...
To qualify as Australia's like break dancer.
And like she's so much better.
She's actually so much better.
I was like, how the fuck...
How the fuck did this girl got in?
So...
So like there's an actual criminal investigation going on now.
About...
About her.
Cause she's not even...
People are like, there's no way.
There's no way.
Anyway, I thought that was crazy.
I thought that was actually absolutely insane.
That...
The IOC is planning on doing an investigation on Australia.
And like on her.
Because like apparently...
It could have been rigged.
And she was actually not supposed to be representing Australia.
Um...
So...
Yeah...
Uh...
And...
Yeah...
And I...
Also like...
I was so surprised.
She's like a professor in break dancing.
How is that a thing?
I can't believe in Australia.
You can be a...
You can write a thesis on break dancing.
I was like...
What?
You can be a prof...
You can get a PhD in break dancing.
It just keeps getting deeper.
The hole just keeps getting deeper and deeper.
You know what I'm thinking with the super chat.
Thank you.
We're sorry.
I was like...
Oh my god.
But in break dancing?
I was like...
Really?
Oh my god.
What is a thesis even gonna be about?
Do you just break dance for your thesis?
There's like so many things.
I'm so confused.
I'm actually so confused.
That like...
I learned way too much about...
I learned way too much about the situation.
It's like a little rabbit hole into like Australia.
The break dancing community in Australia.
But yeah.
Anyway.
I didn't even realize she scored zero throughout everything.
I was so surprised.
I was like...
Clearly, you know.
Maybe one point for like effort.
But no.
She got...
She got zero on everything.
I was like...
Whoa!
You know, I thought it was funny.
But like...
Now it's very funny.
Now you got me invested.
Gee.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Fifteen years from now, Doki will be a professor of VTubing at Harvard.
I heard you can... there's, like, esports... like, I know you can get, like, scholarship for esports, but now there's, like, um, university courses.
Um, there was... I remember there was, like, a university... I don't remember which university it was, but I read that you can take classes regarding esports.
Um, regarding esports, and there was, like, actual, like, classes dedicated to specific games.
I read this a long time ago.
Let me see if I can... esport university class.
I was, like... I was, like, what?
It was... it was, like... oh, yes, it was, like, a specialization regarding the education of esports.
So, like, you can literally, like, learn about, like, esports as, like, a university course.
And I thought that was super interesting, because I was, like, what kind of degree are you gonna get in that?
Like...
Esports, right?
Okay, this is, like, a little hot take, but, like, esports is such a new, um, a new job market that what's...
I personally think esports is not as profitable as people think it is, but, like, a lot of really old business people are, like, esports is the next big thing.
And they dump, like, millions and millions, hundreds of millions of dollars into it, and they don't see...
They don't see any return... business return.
They don't see any investment return in it.
But, like, everybody's getting... like, the participants are getting paid very well, because, like, the old business people don't know what the fuck is going on.
They don't know what the fuck is going on.
So, like, the participants and the players and, like, the coaches and everybody, like, within that's making it happen are getting paid.
Like...
So,
if they press the button, they make a deal with the person that had like worked for them, it's going to have a valid return.
Because, like, it's not what their eisports represents.
What I'm saying is that...
It doesn't represent their potential, but, like, it's something that is obvious like...
That's where I'm at.
If what I'm saying is...
Like, that's not really where the money... I don't think that's really where the money is in general, and like, it's just, I just think it's like super interesting to see like how much money is being thrown into it, and like, it's just like oil money is being thrown into it right now,
if you guys didn't know, like Saudi Arabia has like, their new like law policy at the moment is like investing heavily into the esports scene, so it's like very interesting.
Um, it's very interesting, you're literally being thrown oil money.
Um, anyway, anyway, it is God of War time!
It is God of War, part two!
I don't know how long I'm gonna be playing today, because I'm a little bit eepy, but maybe the coffee's gonna kick in by then.
Uh, buh buh buh buh buh buh buh buh buh, alright, so, apparently, a lot of people are like telling me that, like, I'm gonna get punished really hard if I keep doing God of Gun.
So, so, today's the day, I'm actually gonna learn new combos.
I also forgot the controls already.
Uh, I, I already forgot the controls, so this is gonna be interesting.
Um, like always, I always forget how to play this video game.
Alright, shield.
Alright, this is gun.
Okay, how do I bring gun back?
Gun, come back.
Come back, gun.
Gun.
Gun?
Oh, okay, I figured it out.
Okay.
Alright, I figured... Alright.
Almost got it.
I almost remembered everything.
Alright.
Okay, and then...
Okay, that's making the boy shoot.
How do I... Okay, that's sheathing my, my gun.
And then...
Uh, it's a gun even harder.
Bros, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Okay, how do I fight normally?
How do I... How do I fight normally?
Okay, I don't.
Wait, okay, give me a second.
I don't remember how to fight normally.
I don't remember how to...
Okay, um, normal fight.
Oh, hold R2.
An R1.
Alright.
Alright, there we go.
There we go.
We figured it out, guys!
Guys, we fucking learned!
What the fuck?!
Okay, and then I throw gun.
Sorry.
Alright, there we go!
We did it!
Yes, I know!
The first thing I did was throw gun, but you don't understand that we were at highground!
You don't understand!
It's just convenient!
What the fuck?!
Of course I'm gonna throw it!
They're literally- oh my god, no, not the fucking desert crocodiles.
Oh god.
Not you too.
Why is there- is the dwarf just letting me fucking kill people?
Oh no.
Oh god.
Here we go.
Please, please, son, help me!
Don't be worthless!
Please, son!
Please!
Okay, we're fine.
All right, we're fine.
Where the fuck did they come from?
Is this even part of the story?
Okay, I need a- where am I supposed to go?
Where- I'm so confused.
All right.
Wait, I hear a crow.
Where's the crow?
I hear him.
I hear you.
I hear you, you government spy.
Don't worry.
I know how to block.
I just don't do it.
Oh shit, okay.
All right, what's this?
What is this?
Do I just... keep hitting?
What is that?
Where's the third one?
One... oh hey, loot!
Okay.
Is that loot or just... what the fuck- you're cold?
The sun is out.
Why are you cold?
A man shouldn't be cold.
We don't get cold.
I'm not even wearing a shirt, boy.
You think I'm fucking cold?
Okay, okay and then Is that?
What am I doing?
All right.
Yes, not only am I father of the year, I'm also mother of the year too.
What?
Oh, I get it.
I'll get it.
And then we do this.
And then we don't do that?
Oh, maybe like this?
Wait, what?
What?
Is this a puzzle?
Is there anything in here?
Please, I'm still waking up.
Please don't do this to me.
God, please.
I don't understand.
Okay, W.
What the fuck?
Oh, that's W!
W.
Now what?
P.
W?
W.
Oh, I've missed.
You can hear the cogwheel slowly turning.
Oh, shit!
There's a second one!
Guys, why didn't you tell me there's a second one?
You can actually hear the cogwheel turning in my fucking brain.
Dad's like...
Oh, shit.
Okay.
All right, we can figure this out.
There are more than one.
And then there's this one.
Okay, we gotta do this.
So I can see...
Wait, wait, that's it!
What do I need?
I need...
Okay, backwards B.
All right.
Shady, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Here we see a wild doki bird.
Let's see how long it takes for her to figure out a puzzle.
All right.
Is that it?
That's a backwards B, guys.
All right, we did it, guys.
Oh, my God.
I actually think I'm like...
I think I'm becoming a bimbo.
I don't think anybody can fix me right now.
I don't think anybody can fix this.
Oh, God.
I went to university.
What is this?
Oh, up we go, boy.
Are we getting closer to the mountain?
Are we?
Is this...
I can't tell.
Where's my axe?
All right.
There it is.
Oh, shit.
What the fuck are you...
That's right.
Die in the poison.
Is he still alive?
Oh, he's dead.
Did I actually do it?
Oh, that's funny.
Wait.
Did he actually die?
He did.
Loser.
All right.
Just loot.
Loot time.
Yay.
All right.
What's in it?
Time to desecrate the gods.
Ooh.
Found armor.
Runic symbols on the simple armor increases the quality of the weapon.
Cool down.
Nice.
It's all right.
It's okay to grave rob because they're not my god.
I don't worship these guys.
That means I can grave rob them because if I don't worship them, they don't exist in my world.
That's how it goes.
Right?
Yeah.
They're not my god.
So like how...
I can't get punished if I don't believe in them.
How can they curse me if like I don't see them as real?
Bye.
Wait.
What?
You lit through the poison?
What the fuck?
That's not how it's supposed to work.
You're supposed to die from your own poison.
It's okay.
I'm gonna beat you up with my arms.
You think I don't have...
I have fucking arms.
That's right.
Get over here.
I'll beat you up with my fucking fists.
You think I don't...
Oh shit.
That's fucking right.
Get these hands.
Get over here.
That's fucking right.
I don't care.
I'm not even gonna fucking grab my axe.
Think I care?
World star.
No.
Get over here.
That's right.
Oh shit.
Oh no.
Maybe I'm gonna get punished.
That's fucking right.
Get over here.
Where did he go?
I can't see.
World star.
Holy shit.
He's beating me up in the corner.
That's fucking right.
Where are you?
I see you.
No, I'm not wasting my rage.
It's a fucking witch.
I'm not gonna waste my rage on it.
What did I update?
Oh, she's not.
Oh, she doesn't care about poison.
Alright.
Nice.
I won my... this is my Olympic gold match.
Alright, I'm a little lost now.
What the fuck was I supposed to...
What's this?
Okay, I don't have access to this yet.
Alright.
I guess like... what is in here then?
What's this?
Open.
I'm doing magic?
I'm a god.
Don't I know magic?
As a god, don't I automatically have magic powers?
For later.
Okay.
Let's see.
Maybe we go this... we have to go this way then.
Alright.
Axe.
Come back.
I really need heals.
What?
No!
Fuck.
That's not what I wanted to do.
No, I wasted my magic.
No, that was magic!
God damn it.
I should've killed more of my family members.
So I can absorb more blood into my skin.
And gain the magic abilities.
Magic does not equal god powers?
Wait, is that a dog?
Is that a good dog?
Can't tell.
Alright, we'll figure it out.
I don't think they're good dogs.
To be fair, I think it's because I threw an axe on them.
Okay, don't worry.
I'll use real fighting powers now.
Don't worry.
Now.
Sorry, I missed.
I'm sorry!
I don't know how arms work!
It's been so long since I used hands!
I didn't know how far my hands were!
I don't know why I have fucking short-ass hands!
Alright, let's see.
Okay, there should be stuff in here.
Alright, we need HP.
You have a family member right there, Justin.
Yep, I need him.
It's like Hansel and Gretel where the witch wants to grow the boy.
I need the boy to get more plump and juicy before I absorb him.
And then I'll be stronger.
Burrito, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
I gotta, like, fatten up the boy before he gets absorbed.
Wait, how is there two?
How do I get to two?
I can't count to two.
The circle of life.
Exactly!
Is this why I have the boy around?
That's why the boy is around.
That's why I keep him alive, right?
Doki, don't say that!
What?
He's got me!
He's killing your kids!
It's like in, like, almost every fucking mytholo- God, like, mythology and shit.
Fire doesn't fucking hurt me.
I'm a god.
Oh, shit.
Okay, wait.
There's, like, a pot right there.
There we go.
Yeah!
It's all- You think- You think gods care about their kids?
Nope!
None of the gods care about their children!
A quick dash attack with a follow-up strike.
Kratos is protected during the dash.
Oh, shit!
Wait, that's cool.
Oh, I do that.
Hold a charge of the white- Oh, not enough XP.
Some care too much?
Okay, we don't- Look, we're not here to talk about Zeus.
We're not- We're not- Alright.
Let's see.
Common chest armor.
Ooh!
I like that.
As long as it's not a shirt, that's all that matters.
You gotta pay the troll's toll to get into that boy's soul.
Exactly!
They know what's up.
I think if Sunny in Philadelphia was ever made in today's- in today's time, that show would get cancelled so fucking quick.
Like- Now it's like- now, like, nobody, like, judges Sunny in Philadelphia cause it's like- it's like when a professor gets tenure.
So you're like, oh, guys.
Look, that show- this is the longest-running comedy series ever, guys.
Like, it's a really- I love Sunny in Philadelphia.
I fucking love Sunny in Philadelphia.
But, like, it's like basically a- It's like a show that just got tenured.
Who is this?
A giant gorilla?
Oh, he doesn't even have sub- subtitles.
Whoa!
Shit, boy!
Boy, you can't die!
You haven't absorbed you!
Wait, I'm a god.
I can regenerate an arm.
Let him eat my arm.
It is Shrek.
Oh!
Cut off your toes.
Wait, what?
What is he doing?
What are you doing here?
Where's the third party?
Wait, you're still fighting me?
Don't worry.
I learned that I have more than one move.
This!
And Raichu, this is it!
This is what I've been waiting for!
Right here!
Right now!
That's fucking- Oh, it's over?
Oh, oh, okay.
Oh.
Okay, I did not realize.
Okay!
Oh, shit!
Okay.
Hey, guys?
You did not- Guys, why is Raichu so- Why is Raichu- Raichu is so short!
I saved that Raichu for like 20 years!
And that's all I get?!
That's all I get!
That's actually all I get after I saved Raichu for like five hours.
Oh, wait, I can attack people.
Okay.
That's right.
All right, stop hitting yourself!
Stop hitting yourself!
That's fucking right!
Yeah, stop hitting yourself!
There we go.
Nice.
Easy.
That's right, now I'm gonna eat your fucking brain.
Because of my myth.
Apparently, it makes you smarter.
All right.
Oh, shit!
I forgot you explode!
All right.
Goodbye.
I'm done.
I'm done playing this game legit.
Oh, shit!
I forgot!
I forgot you can regen!
How do I dodge again?!
I don't remember!
Oh!
Act Gun!
Gun, go!
I forgot how to dodge...
How do I dodge again?
Dodge?
Oh, X!
All right.
That's how you dodge!
Win and down Axe Throw!
Oh, nice.
I guess I got a new enchantment.
Do I have enough XP yet to get more skills?
An impossible material that houses the rage of fire.
Oh!
I can upgrade my gun!
Sweet.
Alright, that was easy.
That was pretty fucking easy.
Alright, into the house we go!
Woo!
What was he guarding?
Mountains... base.
Okay.
I can see why mom wanted us to bring her here.
All I'm saying though, out of all the gods in every mythology and legend...
I would say...
I would say I am currently the best... the nicest one.
The nicest dad.
Out of all of them.
Like, the worst I would say...
The worst I did was that...
I yelled at my kid for not being able to kill.
Every god's child can kill.
But yet my kid decided to be a fucking baby.
What are the other gods gonna say about this?
Huh?
They're gonna be like...
Wow Kratos, your child can't even fucking kill a mere mortal?
Like, what are you teaching him now?
Your child wants to be an artist?
Like...
How am I gonna show my face to all the other gods?
It's so embarrassing.
It's not like he's killing a fucking beast or anything.
It was a human.
A human is like mice.
It's like an ant to a god.
Anyway, let's see.
Alright.
Next thing I know...
He's gonna be like...
Dad, I don't wanna take off my shirt.
I don't want people to see my shirt.
I don't want people to see my nipples.
Boy!
What do you mean about this?
What the fuck is this shadow thing?
Wait, she followed me?
Fucking stalker?
And...
He's gone.
moMI Where is this?
Where?
I don't know.
He is peut- You got killed.shot
What the fuck did you do?
Oh my god!
It doesn't even matter!
We could have killed that pig and she'll still like me.
That's fucked.
That pig like knew her for like maybe like 50 plus years.
I met her... I almost killed that friend and then she's like, that's alright.
I think I like you.
That poor fucking pig.
I literally just met that girl.
Oops, did not mean to do that.
These are vines.
What's the use of having an axe if I can't even kill fucking girls?
That's grass.
We're so in.
We shouldn't have even cured the pig.
We should have ate it to celebrate.
Let's see.
Fatt, welcome to the tomato farm!
Welcome, welcome!
Oh, she's gonna teach me magic?
It doesn't matter what element an axe is.
An axe is an axe!
Can't.
Sindri said it was broken.
Sindri?
The dwarf at the foot of these hills.
He was fixing it when we got here.
No one was there when I passed by.
Perhaps he finished.
Dwarves are awesome.
Let me through.
And irritating, based on the two we have met.
That too.
That's right, fuck these jars in particular.
Give what a turn?
Oh.
Okay.
Yeah, couldn't she help us with the other vine?
Oh, it's the fast pass!
I see there's a shortcut.
Tyr's temple?
Alfheim?
Now she's just saying words.
No one knows.
He just appeared one day.
Soon after, Thor attacked.
And their battle could be felt across all the realms.
Ultimately, it ended in a stalemate.
And Thor returned to Odin empty-handed.
The serpent stayed and grew so large, he now spans all of Midgard.
Oh, is that the dog?
They've hated each other ever since.
Destined to kill each other come Ragnarok.
You believe in Ragnarok?
The fuck do you mean, do you believe in Ragnarok?
The fuck?
Your dad's a god!
Is this where you stop believing?
Anything can happen here but Ragnarok?
No, that's where we draw the line.
The giant snake that fucking encompasses the entire world.
But no, Ragnarok is like...
That's a myth.
Alright, let's see.
Wait, where did the dwarf go?
Maybe we can rob him?
Where the fuck did the dwarf go?
Alright.
I wanted to rob him.
Oh, it's time?
Touch.
Feel.
Oh.
Nevermind.
Open.
There's too...
That's way too much make-believe.
Wait, we don't even know her name.
She's just Witch of the Woods.
Yeah, watch her.
Oh!
My bowstring was soaked in the light of Ulfheim.
It can now re- WAIT!
Are you an elf?
Wait.
It won't just disappear, will it?
How the fuck?
Not as long as the light shines forth.
How the fuck do you know elven magic?
I want one.
Those roots?
What kind of magic is that?
It's Vanir.
From Vanahan?
You know of it?
Just stories.
Mother didn't say much about the Vanir gods.
Just that they're always at war with the Aesir.
As compared to Ulaan Dor.
Where do I go?
Oh!
Use your fucking magic to open the door!
Am I just like...
I'm just a butler for... I'm just a piece of meat for them.
Alright, off we go.
I mean, you are!
Oh, we're back here.
Hello, dog!
Wait!
I just remembered!
Guys!
Wait, I just remembered!
We could have played this game with better graphics now!
Okay, give me a sec.
Give me a sec.
I want better graphics.
Okay, we can actually... Oh my god!
I'm gonna do it!
I'm gonna do 120 FPS!
Okay, what is it?
Is it... Oh, yes!
Yes!
Okay, let me bring up my task manager just in case.
Oh!
Guys!
Guys, is that 99%?
99% CPU.
Okay, maybe...
Okay, maybe I was a little too confident.
Maybe I was... I was a little too confident.
Okay.
That was actually...
Okay, we won't do ultra performance.
Okay.
Wait.
Okay, here we go.
Oh, no!
Not this!
I want...
All right.
Guys.
I think... I think...
That's fine.
I can do it with 120 FPS.
So, we're okay now.
It was the CPU that was like...
You're getting a little bit too cocky there.
Okay.
All right.
That should be fine.
That should be fine, right?
All right.
Nice.
Okay.
120 now.
Maybe I was a little too cocky.
Maybe...
Maybe I was a little too cocky here.
Maybe I'll do...
I'll do 100 and...
My...
I see my...
My CPU being like, please.
Okay.
All right.
Here we go.
Oh.
If I do this, does it make it prettier?
This...
I still don't really know what DLSS actually...
Actually does.
I just listen to what you guys tell me to do.
Okay.
It helps perform.
It makes it uglier.
Oh!
Okay.
We don't want that.
We want it to look beautiful.
It's that original graphics.
Do I make Ultra?
Guys!
I want Ultra!
I'm gonna do it!
Guys!
I'm gonna do it.
We don't care about...
Okay.
I don't care about reflection.
All right.
It looks the same.
I don't see any difference to be fair.
All right.
Okay.
Make a right at the bottom of these stairs.
Go down here.
I don't know what's different.
Where the fuck?
It looks...
Literally looks the same.
Hey!
Another one of those light crystals.
Wait there while I reawaken the light.
Leosta.
Look at the faces.
Boy!
I need to look at your face boy.
Come over here.
Are you HD?
Yeah.
I'm gonna go with this.
Bro, it looks the same!
I can't tell!
I actually can't tell!
He looks the same!
I guess I can see like the fur on his fucking shirt.
Oh, I gotta lift.
Don't worry.
I am a piece of meat and I'm ready to do... I'm ready to show you my muscles.
Use photo mode?
Okay.
Press H.
Got it.
Where am I pushing?
Oh!
Whoa!
You want help out?
Are you just gonna sit there?
First position?
I'm not tired!
Look at my abs!
That's right!
I'm dehydrated!
But I'm not tired!
The boy said boy.
Hellwalkers?
What are they?
They are poor, restless souls.
Denied their judgment and their peace.
By what?
Could Vanir magic raise the dead?
It could, once.
But this is no spell.
This plague of dead is but a symptom of a world out of...
Wait, what made it out of balance?
It can't be me, right?
Someone has meddled with powerful forces.
That is all I know for sure.
Is it because I invaded this land?
Is that why?
I'm not because I'm a Norse god.
No, I'm not a Norse god.
I'm a Greek god.
I forgot!
Sorry, there's too many gods in this world.
I forgot which type of god I am.
Is it because I'm a Greek god in the Norse world?
I didn't hurt your back, did you?
I did not.
Through these doors.
Wait, so did the giants or the elves build Tearstone?
Who built this?
All the races helped with its construction.
It was the last great act of cooperation...
They worked together?
No way!
Elves are super racist!
We all know that!
They've always been racist!
Alright, let's see.
In we go.
Not right!
You guys don't know?
No matter what genre, elves have always been racist.
No matter what game.
No matter what history.
We just hate everything.
That's not elves!
Your bowstring stopped glowing.
Its power is now depleted.
Only a few knocks of magic remained in the bowstring and we used them.
Oh it's the string.
Your bow please.
Wait, My boy ain't getting pussy elf magic?!
How fucking dare you!
This is...
This is a crutch!
How dare you!
How dare you give him some pussy ass elf magic!
Now he'll never be strong!
The gods don't care for me much.
Now he'll be weak forever!
He'll never learn!
This temple has been asleep underwater for almost 150 winters.
It needs only the light of the Bifrost to reawaken.
Oh, Bifrost.
I know what Bifrosts are.
Weak ass elf magic.
It's not true strength.
Magic's not real.
Magic's just illusion, boy.
You wanna be a fucking magician, boy?
First an artist, now a magician?
Why are you always a disappointment?
That of the year, 2024.
Alright, we gotta go to the...
table.
How does it work?
You will need this.
A Bifrost.
To create travel between realms.
Magic is temporary.
Muscle is forever.
Place the Bifrost there.
True strength comes from gains, Arceus.
What now?
Give it a moment.
The temple needs time to wake up from its long slumber.
It is from this room, and this room alone.
That you will be able to cross between realms.
Oh!
What you see before you represents the temple in which we stand.
So I get to go to another realm.
As well as the realm towers that encircle the lake of nine outside.
All the realms exist in the same physical space, reflections of each other.
These doors, the towers outside, and the nine realms are all intertwined and coexisting on the branches of the world tree.
Separated only by the Bifrost light of Alfheim.
This place can focus and control that light.
And is this the world tree?
Only an artistic representation of it.
No, the Yggdrasil is much, much more than this.
Wait, where's the...
The tree of life is bound to the fate of the world.
Where's the Yggdrasil so I can burn it?
Just as we are bound to it.
If I burn the tree, then all the realms die.
The dew from its leaves beat our valleys and rivers.
Is that what we want?
The tree's very existence supports all of creation along its bounds.
Its life energy interwoven into the tapestry of life.
Birth, growth, death, and rebirth.
Every strand transcending time, transcending space.
Everything comes back to the tree.
What if I just burn it?
So, that's how it works.
But I'm guessing you were looking for a more practical answer.
Yes.
Oh!
The bridge you pushed outside is currently positioned to lead to the realm of Vanaheim.
Instead, turn the wheel to our actual destination.
Alfheim.
Okay.
The world of the elves.
We need to destroy the elves.
Is this moving the big bridge outside?
Yes.
Oh, Jotunheim!
That's the ice world.
And the bridge aligns to the different realm towers on the lake outside.
Wait, there's no tower on this one.
And that's why realm travel to Jotunheim is impossible.
Wait, why?
Without a tower for the bridge to lock into, the sequence can't begin.
It's time to kill all the elves.
Every realm has a travel route that locks the bridge to Vanaheim.
You're teaching my boy fucking magic.
I'm giving you the run for Alfheim.
Now you can lock in your destination.
If I destroy the elves, my boy will finally go to the gym.
We're ready.
Remember to take the Bifrost.
You don't want to lose that.
Alright.
Now the realm travel bridge will align.
And the realm between realms...
Oh, get out of here.
Let's see.
See that giant crystal?
Yeah.
Each realm has a corresponding one that focuses and amplifies the power of the Bifrost.
Opening the bridge to that realm.
That's why realm travel is only possible from this room.
What about that one realm tower on the second lake?
Why is nobody guarding this place?
The tower disappeared from all realms over a hundred years ago.
Oh, I killed all of them.
When the giants vanished from Midgard.
Where the tower went and how they moved it remain a mystery.
Oh, is this a loading screen?
This is really pretty for a loading screen.
What the fuck do you mean, boy?
We're not outside yet.
We're inside the tower.
Boy, this is what happens when you become a magician.
You're like too much on magic.
Hey,
what the fuck are you doing?
Can you just let me go?
I think I want to die.
Oh, that's me.
You're an idiot, boy.
I think I want to die but I can't.
I'm dead.
You need to die, boy.
Oh, a joint?
Oh, a joint.
You need to die, boy.
I can't, I can't.
I can't.
Alright.
Ooh!
Okay, we're back here.
Did we bring the dwarf with us?
What happened to the dwarf?
If he's not here manning the station, I could have stolen... I should be allowed to steal his shit if he's not here.
How would he know?
Whoa!
Nature!
More stuff to cut!
I like how you guys are saying, like, the temple was underwater.
Yeah, but like, we're gods!
Gods don't need to breathe!
Breathing is a concept!
The light?
Oh!
What's happening?
Wait, what?
What the fuck?
Wouldn't they, like, position the god of, like, the ocean slash water to guard this place?
There's gods for everything!
I don't think she's allowed to be here, I guess.
I think she's on house arrest or something.
Don't touch these.
These were made by elves.
Don't you touch them.
What's that?
Can I cut this?
Nice.
Okay.
Her visa got denied.
Good!
Fuck Nature.
Do not touch the elves, boy.
Elves made this place.
Oh, hey!
Boy, read!
Yes, sir!
What does it say?
Hmm.
Something about an eternal war for the light.
Eternal war for the light?
If both sides need it.
Okay.
Why not just share it?
Greed.
You will find it a common cause for war.
Oh shit, are these dead elves?
Good!
Is that an elf?
Wait, elves can fly?
They keep murdering the lighthouse.
Oh shit!
No, that's good!
Yeah, fuck you!
Oh wait, no, wait.
Wait, who are these?
Are these also elves?
Wait, who the fuck are these?
What are you?
Oh shit!
Are you elves?
I can't tell!
Are you also elves?
Wait, why can they fly?
Get out of here!
That's fucking right!
Doesn't matter, you're still an elf!
Oh, they're also elves?
Oh, they're all elves!
I told you, boy!
This is why we gotta exterminate these elves!
How dare you think you can fly?
Oh shit, it's dark!
Is that a gang war?
Are we in dark elf territory?
More will come.
Alright, let's see.
Dark elf!
Unlike the light elves of ElfHim, the dark elves prefer dark places.
Maybe that's why they wanted to cover up the light.
They can fly and seem pretty smart and well coordinated.
More so than most of the enemies we've fought so far.
Oh, so they're like little mosquitoes!
What do the light elves look like?
So light elves have to be stuck on the ground and dark elves can fly?
That's fucked!
That's actually fucked, holy shit!
Yeah, that's how...
Yeah, you don't get to fucking fly!
They're like little mosquitoes!
Told you, boy!
I told you, boy, to get rid of those goddamn elf magic!
Sis!
Break it!
Oh, okay.
What did I get?
Another cipher piece!
Ooh!
Let's see if I can fit together!
We're gonna learn the magic!
Do light elves...
Are light elves the hippies?
Are they like hippies?
Like, what the fucking...
Ooh, oh my god, they are!
They don't wear shoes!
Ugh!
Do I wear shoes?
I do, cause I'm...
I do, cause I'm not a fucking elf!
Ooh, compass aren't...
When a compass turns gold, an objective is somewhere in the area.
Search the area for clues!
Okay!
I'm gonna get rid of these...
Because the god of war doesn't like nature.
Wait, what?
They regenerate?
What the fuck?
Why the fuck is that regenerating?
Cause they taught my boy magic!
Oh, it's like bowling!
It's like bowling!
I'm so fucking smart!
Look what they did to my boy!
All he does is magic now!
And that is why I, as father of the year, shall hate all elves because of one thing that happened to him.
Hello!
Oh, it's the simp!
Wait,
why are you doing an elf again?
Ah, hang on to that sense of wonder.
There's so little mystery once you've amassed the wealth of arcane knowledge that I have.
Where to comb the realms for exotic resources.
How to craft them into creations that defy imagination.
To the novice, I'm sure it all seems like magic.
But...
Oh, alright.
It's magic.
Are you happy now?
Okay.
Upgrade my stuff.
Oh, I got an upgrade!
Nice!
Yay!
Okay.
What kind of upgrade do I have?
Um...
Oh, do I get chest armor upgrade?
Wait, do I get better armor though?
Compare.
Uh, minus 14.
Minus...
No, you're not taking away my strength.
How about this?
Hmm...
No, I like my strength.
I don't need defense.
Oh, you're fine.
You don't fucking need armor.
You live forever.
Unique...
For...
Oh!
Can I add that?
Do I have a handle already or nah?
Let's see.
Plus two, plus six.
Plus six.
Uh...
Alright, we'll get this.
I mean, we do have hack silver for it.
Oh, it's so expensive though.
Maybe not.
This is way too expensive.
Okay, let's upgrade, I guess.
Uh...
What am I wearing?
Okay, I'm wearing this.
I don't have enough stuff.
So...
Woo...
Okay, 750...
Plus defense.
Minus eight?
I'm upgrading it.
How?
How is upgrading it taking away my strength?
It's so dumb.
Okay.
Enchantments.
I don't know what I'm doing, guys.
I...
Guys, can you tell I don't know what I'm doing?
No, right?
Does it look like I'm a natural?
I'm not.
Do I look at this?
Okay, let's see.
I wanna make sure I have... do I have sockets?
What am I wearing?
Okay.
Do I not have anything?
Oh, I do!
Symbol of Truth, plus 3.
Okay.
Alright, I have a socket on this.
Nice, okay.
Oh, I can have a... wait, when do I have equip this?
Okay.
No, I don't have any more.
I should have enough for skills, too.
I'm pretty sure.
Am I level 3 yet?
Okay, now... now let's actually upgrade our other close combat.
Multiple times and that deals massive... Oh, I like massive damage!
Oh!
Wait, that's so cool!
Okay, I can't do combos.
I'm too fucking stupid for that.
You know what?
Let's do this.
Yeah!
Alright, let's see what else.
Shield combat.
To break an enemy's block.
To sweep off enemies.
Wild Bear evade and press L.
Wild Bear hand and hold R2 to perform a shield slam and inflict moderate damage.
Why the fuck would I use... oh, wait.
Why would I use my fist, though?
Okay, I guess I'll give you something.
Acrobatic...
Increase the fire rate.
Increase... oh, arrow damage!
Alright, you get that upgrade.
What is... what are these?
Hold to select three targets on... oh, wait, what?
I get to select three targets?
Throw axe.
Yeah, but I have all the throw axe.
Oh, what do I get?
Oh, a massive explosion!
Wait, I like explosions!
Explosion means more damage!
Alright, nice.
Now Boy is just a little stronger.
Alright, Boy, get in here!
Get in here, Boy!
What'd you say?
I said nothing.
Really?
Okay.
Oh my god, you fucking broke the fourth wall.
That's right, Boy, I said get in here!
Okay, well, I'll go this way.
Okay, but what if I go this way, though?
What is this way?
Lead me.
Oh, shit!
Oh, I can't.
There's like something above that I can shoot.
Boy is hearing the VTuber.
Alright, we go this way, then.
Oh, what?
Boy, I told you!
I told you!
Did you touch anything that else made?
It's going all the way now.
I was screaming.
Lots of voices.
Angry.
You really didn't hear that?
No.
I told you, Boy!
It's the elf magic's fault, Boy!
I told you!
We warned you, Boy!
Alright.
Those damn fucky elves.
Let's go.
Oh, hey!
There's more lighters!
Hello, lighters!
Or maybe they need help.
I know I said a lot of shit about you guys, but okay.
See, this is why!
This is why I'm prejudiced now!
You're only encouraging my prejudice against elves!
This is all your fault!
The one time I gave you a chance!
You encour- This is why!
The one time!
Time!
I gave them a chance!
The twins were right!
Let's see...
I'll go this way.
Here
we go.
Ooh!
I wonder why there's like a gang war between the Dark Elves and the Light Elves.
Like, what happened?
Whoa!
That's so pretty!
Alright.
I see so many dead Light Elves, but like, no...
no dead Dark Elves.
Oh my god, you guys are the hippies.
Alright, boy.
It's time.
Read.
What if I'm ruining?
Okay.
I have to find more stuff.
Wait.
You guys hear that?
What is that?
I heard like...
I heard like some monster near me.
I don't know if that's like ambient noise or something.
There's like...
There's like ahhh!
That's an ambient noise.
I thought it was like an enemy.
Are there any fish around?
Are there any fishes in the water?
I don't like how there just seems like no life in the water.
Some house can't work things out.
How if I'm such a beautiful place?
But war makes it ugly.
The blue door!
That's gotta be the entrance.
Let's go!
That's where all the runics are, right?
Careful, boy.
What are they doing?
What is happening there?
Oh, shit!
What's going on?
Oh, they are invading it.
Oh shit, where is my axe?
That's fucking right.
Oh shit, I missed!
Wait, I upgraded it.
Give me a sec.
Wait, you can block?
That's illegal.
Wait, no!
Please, I'm trying to use my new thing.
Okay.
Okay, now I'm angry.
Now I'm angry!
Please!
I'm still angry!
Okay, I got this.
Shoot your arrow!
I upgraded you for a reason!
Alright, nice.
There you go.
Now I'm actually angry.
Before then I was pretending angry, now I'm really angry.
Alright.
I guess we go this way then.
If they prevented the... Oh, nope.
Nope, I guess not.
How do we get across?
Do I just... How do we get down there though?
Do we just jump down?
What's that sound?
Oh, it's the other dark elves!
That's what the sounds were.
Wait, can we get down there?
Oh!
There's things here.
I don't know what this does.
I assume it's like an elec- what?
What did I do?
Okay.
It's like a bridge?
Oh!
Okay.
Okay, don't worry.
I learned a new thing.
Okay, I'm blocking everything.
Okay, fuck this.
Now I'm... fuck this.
Fuck gun!
Alright, that's fine.
That's fucking right.
What are you gonna do?
Blah.
Oh!
Okay, that's what you're gonna do.
Okay.
That makes sense.
That's fucking right.
Fly away from this!
Can't fly away from my fucking arms!
Oh!
Okay, you know, fuck you in particular.
And that's how you do it.
Alright.
Alright, let's see.
Oh!
Update!
Like to attack as a group.
Alright.
That's right.
I gotta teach him a lesson.
That one guy lesson.
What am I doing?
Is that a room?
Oh!
Okay.
Back to the sand bowl I go.
Boy, you just need to read harder.
Alright.
Oh!
Activated and like stuff over here too!
Sound time!
Alright.
You see that, boy?
This is what happens to magicians.
Told you to go to the gym with father.
Instead you learn fucking magic.
You see how that magic helped those dark elves?
You see that?
Now they're fucking dead.
Alright, read, boy.
Read.
I told you reading was a mistake.
Oh, the light elves.
The light elves are asking for help.
I do not care who they are nor what they want.
You never care about anything.
You have something to say.
Oh, he's fucking going through his...
He's going through puberty right now.
He's going through his rebellious stage.
Damn.
What's happening?
Say it louder, boy.
Say it to my fucking face.
There's just no other shit?
Father?
Yes?
The voices I heard.
It was hard to make out.
But way in the back I'm pretty sure I heard.
Mother.
Huh?
That is not possible.
Mother?
Atreus.
Enough.
She's dead.
We burned her together.
You don't even have shoes, too.
That can't be good.
Oh yeah, that's definitely not good.
Who do I hate more?
I gotta be sure.
You know?
I gotta be sure who I hate more.
I need to know who I'm killing first.
Oh shit.
What the fuck did I do?
I don't know.
Oh.
You can't fly.
You're frozen.
That's fucking right.
Oh, I need grab healers.
Oh fuck.
Okay.
Nice.
Oh no, I can't block.
Okay.
Okay, this is it.
Yeah.
Fuck you.
That's fucking right.
Oh.
Okay.
No, that's not block.
Come on.
Oh shit.
No, yeah.
Fuck you.
Jesus.
These executions are like so brutal.
How did I make access?
Explode?
I don't know.
Mash button.
Things die.
Oh.
Oh, wait.
There's stuff behind me.
Oh shit.
You can deal with that, right?
I'm gonna go loot.
Looting it.
You see, boy.
Looting is more important.
Wait.
The fuck is that?
How do I free it?
Wait.
There's stuff here.
Can I like...
Oh shit.
Oh my god.
How did you guys get here?
Okay.
Oh.
Oh no.
Oh, that's a big boy.
That's a big boy.
Oh god.
Okay.
Nice.
Don't worry.
We're fine.
We're so fine.
We're so healthy.
We are so healthy right now.
It's okay.
I'm mashing every button I know.
Can you guys tell?
Okay.
All right.
And they're all dead.
Nice.
Wait.
There's more?
How is there more?
Okay.
Shoot your arrow.
And now I'm gonna fucking teach him a lesson.
That's right.
Where are your abs?
Huh?
How dare you not wear a shirt with no abs?
That's fucking right.
All right.
Stay away from those cages.
Can I free them?
Yeah.
Be ready.
What?
I did it!
Oh shit!
They're bad people!
Okay.
Never mind.
I legitimately thought they were gonna, you know, give me something, but I guess not.
All right.
Yay!
Wait.
Chat's dead?
How long has Chat been dead?
I didn't even notice.
Wait.
Chat's been dead this whole time.
Oops.
I didn't even notice Chat's been dead this whole time.
All right.
Give me a sec.
Let me...
Let me put you guys back into the game.
It's because of this new OBS update.
The new OBS update has, like, killed Chat.
So, like, I always have to, like, fucking manually revive you guys every stream, but I'm not used to it.
I'm not used to doing that.
How do I get in there?
I want to open the chest.
What?
Use your fucking magic.
What's the point?
Oh, shit.
Nice.
Thank you.
They're dead.
It doesn't matter.
Oh.
This way.
Okay.
That should open that, right?
What?
What did I destroy, then?
Wait.
Okay.
Oh, it's coming back.
What's the angle?
Oh!
Okay.
Oh, no.
That's just loot.
Wait.
Then, how do I...
Huh?
How do I do this?
There's apparently an angle?
What?
I can't go through that.
Think, Doki.
Think!
Okay.
Oh!
I have...
I know!
Watch this.
Fucking knew it.
I'm so goddamn smart.
There we go.
Okay.
Let's go.
Nice.
A heavy runic attack.
That's called simple geometry.
Yeah.
That's right.
I played Overwatch.
All right.
Nice.
I would like my free item, please.
I wonder if they have stuff I can loot.
I guess not.
I don't think there's any items in there.
All right.
I guess we head over here.
Come on, boy.
Come on.
Boy, you gotta get rid of your elf magic.
Oh, what's this?
What's this over there?
It's red.
Okay.
Let's see.
I need to turn these cogs.
Okay.
And then...
And now...
Put it here?
Okay.
We will find out.
And then...
How do I get up?
Oh, did I fuck it up?
Brain hurt.
Is this...
Oh, no.
That's where I have to go.
Okay.
And then...
No!
Oh, okay.
Very tricky.
Okay.
Let's see.
I just need to do, like, tiny.
Okay.
Is it tiny?
No.
We don't do tiny.
Okay.
And then...
We push again.
Oh.
Put it in here.
Okay.
Oh.
Whoa.
No.
That's not what I wanted to do.
Okay.
Did we do it?
Oh, there we did.
That's fucking right.
Fuck you.
Where's the other seal?
Oh, there it is.
Oh.
We're missing one more seal.
How do we get over there?
Huh.
The last seal is, like, over here.
But...
How do we get high enough?
Huh?
Is that not where the seal is at?
It's blue.
It's blue, though.
It's not blue?
Oh.
Okay.
We'll lower the platform.
Oh?
Wait.
Okay.
Is there anything in here?
No?
Okay.
We'll lower again.
It's not the lower...
Oh, wait.
I was like, why no turn?
Is there anything behind me?
Okay.
And lower even more?
Maybe it's here.
Oh!
No!
Wait.
Can I lower even more?
Okay.
No!
I got this, guys.
Yeah!
Nice.
I'm so smart.
Now, if a regular player plays this game, they'll figure it out.
Okay.
I figured it out in, like, five hours.
I figured it out in, like, four hours.
Yay!
More HP!
Okay.
How do we get that?
Wait.
Is there, like...
Can I get that chest behind me?
How do I get that?
Up.
Oh!
Guys, did you know circles climb?
Guys, I learned how to climb!
You see, if you play the game, it takes you, like, six hours.
When I play the game, it took me, like, five hours.
That's when you know I'm not like other gamers.
Okay.
Nice.
All right.
Okay.
Yippee!
I'm so smart!
Guys, I'm the fucking god of war, not god of wisdom.
I'm just RPing.
Oh, where did I come from?
Oh, this way.
Guys, I'm just role-playing guys.
I'm just being immersive.
Okay...
What does this even...
Hey.
I didn't even turn.
Why am I turning?
There's like stuff in here.
So that means like...
I might be able to break something?
Like what did I do?
What the fuck did I do?
Why did I open?
Did I even open anything?
Like I can't...
Wait, what the fuck is that?
I looked at the wrong area.
Okay, there you go.
I did open something.
Okay.
Alright.
Sorry, I looked at the wrong place.
I didn't realize.
Alright.
Open sesame.
Your god's not real.
Noink.
Reduces all damage.
Oh yay!
Nice.
I wonder if like...
There's more stuff.
Okay.
Alright.
Let's lower...
Oh!
I literally just lowered it back!
Oh, I can equip it!
You're right!
Where's the equipment thing?
Wait, what did I even get?
This is like...
Is it like a...
Oh, there it is.
There it is.
Oh, hello!
Okay, line it up.
Nice.
What did I do?
What the fuck did I do?
Did I do this?
Oh, it's here.
Up you go, Arteus.
Oh shit!
Okay, that was pretty dumb of me.
Oh, thank god.
Oh shit!
Get him off!
I'm angry!
Get over here!
That's fucking right!
Off you go!
Off you go too!
That's right!
Even though you have wings, off you go!
Oh shit, you can fly back?
Where's that?
Oh my god, I can't believe it!
They can fly back!
I can't believe they used their fucking wings!
That should be illegal!
Is he gonna shoot him?
Shoot him, boy!
Fucking shoot him!
Shoot him!
What are you doing?
Just shoot him, boy!
Oh my god, boy!
Where's my fucking axe?
Boy, please!
Boy!
Shoot your fucking gun!
How do I fight them?
What do you mean?
I can't go anywhere!
Oh, sorry, I make my own path.
I forgot I could make my own path.
I have them literally so strong.
Boy!
Look, I wanted to see my boy fucking shoot him!
What's the point of learning these pussy ass elf magic if you can't shoot them?
Sorry, I forgot I was a god for a second.
Yeah.
Oh my- and you miss!
Okay.
You could've shot them like five minutes ago when they were point blank.
But now you miss.
It's alright, boy.
I wish my daughter was still alive.
Alright.
Get down!
Get the fuck down!
That's right, you shouldn't have fucking- That's right, you shouldn't have touched the ground!
This is my territory!
I rule here!
Alright.
Wait, where did she go?
Oh no, it's too- Too dark.
That's fucking right- Oh!
Timed it wrong.
I didn't know when that was- When that starts.
Alright, get down.
That's right, I'm gonna swat you like a mosquito.
Get an electric fly swatter.
Alright.
Where do I go?
This type seems stronger than the average dark elf.
They swing their heavy weapon so hard it creates a shockwave.
Okay.
Yeah, I feel like I should've definitely invested in the shield counter.
Hey, you sure the witch is okay?
I'd hate to think she died helping us.
She knew what she was doing.
Let's see...
Oh, this is the right way.
Okay, that means I can explore more behind me, right?
Let's see...
Let me grab the shield counter.
Maybe you guys were right.
Maybe I should've invested in the shield.
Alright, which one was it?
Which one was the good one?
Oh my god, I have so many shield upgrades.
Holy shit!
Alright guys, which one is it?
Maybe a skill required.
Which one do I get?
Yeah, but I don't want things where I have to use my hands.
Chat is never right.
Axe only.
Is it this?
No, this is for...
Is it this one?
Is it the double tap to break an enemy?
Or is it...
Uh...
Alright, one...
While sprinting...
Uh...
Oh!
Okay, but that has to be bare-handed.
I don't like that.
I don't like the bare-handed one.
Blocking and protecting at the last second absorbs...
Oh, this one!
It's this one!
Okay.
Alright.
That can help me block the projectile.
Fuck faces.
Oh, hey!
Nice, HP.
Okay.
Wait, where's the...
Where's your fucking...
Uh, plaid thing?
It's not a plaid thing?
Or this?
It's the plant that ties it together...
Oh, here it is!
There you are.
Wait, what?
There's more of you?
Huh?
There's more?
Where is it growing from?
Wait...
Where could it be growing from?
Okay...
Is it...
I literally only see one.
Where the fuck is the other one?
Where could it be growing from?
There's nothing else glowing.
Is there?
Oh my god.
This is why I hate plants.
Oh, hey!
Loot!
Is it up or...
Is it higher or lower?
Oh, there it is!
Okay, how the fuck do I do this?
Okay...
How the fuck?
Uh...
Okay...
I...
I don't know.
Do I need like...
A skill?
How the fuck do you do geometry?
Oh!
Wait...
Recall it from here?
Maybe?
God damn it!
Okay...
Oh, it curves!
It curves!
Okay...
Alright, I do this...
And then I do a little boomerang!
From here!
Okay, not from there.
Okay, it's not from there.
Maybe like...
Here?
And then...
Here.
What the fuck?
Alright, no, not from here.
Uh...
Here?
And then we go from here?
And then
we go from here?
And then we go from here?
Not yeah!
Nevermind, not yeah.
Not...
Not yeah.
Okay, from here...
And then...
Here.
God fucking...
Okay...
I shall learn geometry!
Here!
Okay...
And then...
Right here.
That has to be it.
I did it!
I think I brute-forced it, but...
If it works, it works.
Fucking geometry.
Geometry.
That's right.
I did it.
Alright, here we go.
I don't know if I actually brute-forced it or if I did it correctly.
Alright.
Here we go.
First try.
Simple geometry.
Ooh!
What's that red glowing light over there?
Is it dangerous?
More of it.
Oh, bullying!
Okay.
Bullying time!
If we cut enough away, the bridge above us should reappear.
Right.
This way.
If it works, it works, guys.
See?
It doesn't matter if I almost failed math.
Anybody can solve this.
This shit's for babies.
If they didn't think of a 10, give this shit a sticky thank you!
Where did I go?
Oh, here.
It's not in yellow paint, so it's hard to figure out where to go.
Alright, this way.
Here we go.
Oh shit, no.
More elves.
It's fucking right.
Oh shit!
Don't worry.
Don't worry, I upgraded my shit!
I don't just use guns!
But sometimes guns is the right thing to use.
Oh, nice.
HP.
Above me?
Oh, fuck!
Okay, don't worry.
Nice.
Okay, and now I'm angy.
That's fucking right.
Pew, pew, pew, pew, pew!
Oh, fuck!
Okay, that's how I meant.
Sorry.
Did not mean to get angry there.
Alright, fuck you.
Fuck you!
That's right.
Try and fly from that!
You can't!
Wait, where did he go?
Wait, what?
Where is he?
There's still fucking...
angry music.
Who's angry?
Oh, you're angry!
Oh, you're just stuck!
I was like, who's angry right now?
Oh, shit!
Rocks?
Good question!
Oh, shit!
Shoot it!
Oh!
What is he doing?
Shoot the rock!
What?
Oh!
My pain is not your concern!
Do I just...
Throw your knife!
Throw your... Oh my god!
Okay!
Okay.
Come on!
Do the thing!
That's fucking right!
Why is it not working?
Oh, shit!
I need my heals!
There we go!
Alright.
Shoot it!
Here we go!
I found the perfect cover!
That's right!
You can't do shit now!
That's fucking right!
I'm always fighting!
Jeez!
Get out of here!
Oh!
I'll fucking punch you in the heart!
Oh, no!
That's right!
What are you gonna do now?
Huh?
What you gonna do now?
Nothing!
That's right!
You can't walk forward!
Oh, shit!
Not open your fucking heart!
This is not fair!
This is actually not fair!
Alright.
Open your heart!
That's fucking right!
Easiest shit of my life!
Can't walk forward, nerd!
Yeah!
Elf magic can't save you now!
Reduces all damage!
Oh, hey!
Reduces damage again!
Nice!
Oh my god!
That's a lot of shit!
Oh!
Now I see that!
Alright!
Shoot him!
Yeah!
Okay!
Fucking right!
Should've went to the gym!
Instead of relying on elf magic!
Nice!
We did it!
I have brute force!
I use my brain!
Light runic attack!
Clears out surrounding...
Oh!
Oh, hey!
That's good!
Oh, I'm broke!
Am I still broke?!
Oh!
Wait, I just never equipped it!
Oops!
Okay...
Rapidly spinning attack that clears out...
A quick...
Uh...
With a follow-up...
Extremely burst of...
Oh, actually, I think this...
Honestly, I think this is my favorite so far.
Wait!
4 damage!
Never mind!
This is my favorite!
Ungabunga!
Huh?
Mega chop!
Mega chop didn't win?!
Oh!
I...
I already chopped it!
Ooh!
Yeah!
I made a bridge!
I did it!
I brought the light!
Wait!
See?
If the boy calls me smart, I am smart.
What if I can, like, grab more arrows?
Didn't the witch give me...
How do I get to here?
Okay...
I wanna open this so I can grab the loot.
I don't know how to open it.
How the fuck do I open doors?
Oh, wait.
Unless...
Why does my axe not go through?
Boy!
Get in there, boy!
Boy, you fit!
Boy, I can...
I know you fit under...
I know you fit that gate!
Boy, I need that chest!
Crawl under that gate right now!
Alright, up we go.
Yeah, you thought...
You think I don't know?
I know you fucking fit under that gate.
I know what size you are!
Boy, he don't bite!
It's like a dog!
The blue door.
Okay, this way.
Oh, it's so pretty!
I really love the graphics.
We have a problem.
What do you mean by there's no seam?
Oh, I can't open it!
Unless...
If I caress it enough...
These doors do not open.
Hello?
If I say something nice to it...
Hey there, pretty girl.
Have I ever told you that you're the most beautiful door out there?
If I caress it enough, maybe it'll open.
Oh, hey!
Wait, how did you get here?
Oh my god, Lore!
Boy, read.
It's time to read, boy.
There's giants and sorcerers.
Negative risk closes even more.
Did Odin kill her for her book?
Hey, door.
You wanna open your...
You wanna open your hinges?
Spread your hinges for me?
Hey there.
You wanna...
You wanna spread your hinges for me?
So I can go inside...
Okay.
It's a fucking door!
What do you mean?
We need call HR!
It's a fucking door!
Did you kill an ancient?
Yes.
Was it difficult?
Is that all you're going to give me?
Yes.
Never dirty talk a door.
Let's do it.
What are you talking about?
I'm just trying to get the door to open up!
That's all I want!
Ew, I'm not fucking upgrading your shit.
Boy, you don't deserve that.
I'm just gonna wait for better upgrades.
Baby, you're not like other door.
Hater, baby door.
Oh, is that it?
Alright, let's go this way.
Is this the right way?
Oh wait, no, this is the right way.
But there's like another entrance.
Is this the entrance?
I can't tell.
There's like so many pathways.
Let me ring your doorbell.
Oh yeah, there is another.
What's this for?
Oh!
Okay.
So...
Where is it heading to though?
Like, where's the other one?
Wait, where's the... is it up here?
Is that your... no, are you just happy to see me?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I'm trying to figure out like, um...
Where the other thing I'm supposed to cut?
Like, what is... what is the next thing I'm supposed to cut?
That's the thing, I don't know...
This?
I can't tell.
Is it that?
What the fuck is...
Oh, it's that!
Oh, okay, I see.
Sorry, I don't know how to look right.
I see it now.
There we go.
Sorry, I didn't know which door I...
I didn't look right.
Sorry, my eyes are only for one door, guys.
Guys, I only have eyes for one door, chat.
Like...
You really think I was gonna cheat on that door?
After everything we've been through?
Alright.
Let's see...
Guys...
It's monogamy.
Guys, that door is made of monogamy.
Let's see...
Alright.
I think we got everything.
I think so?
Yeah.
Alright.
We go this way.
Let's see...
Here we go.
You will not...
You would knock on more than one door.
I would never!
My eyes are for that door only.
You would knock on more than one door only.
Of course.
Oh, wait.
He was just...
He was cutscene.
No, it was cutscene!
I did not miss!
Okay.
You know what?
Fuck this.
I'm angry.
I'm gonna go straight to you.
Straight to you!
That's fucking right!
Dodge this!
Fucking dodge this bitch!
That's right.
World star!
Oh!
Sorry, I did not mean that.
Oh.
Oh, I can't dodge that?
This fucking sucks.
Get down from here.
Get down!
Fight me like a real man!
Even though you're an elf!
Come on!
Get down from here!
I'll fucking swat you with my electric swatter!
Doki smash!
Phew!
There you go.
He's dead.
All right.
What the fuck?
What?
Okay, we gotta figure this out.
This one is able to call...
Oh, okay.
Yeah.
That was a good move by me then.
All right.
That has to go down, right?
No?
Okay.
Oh, I know.
It has to be the heavy attack.
How did I miss?
Wait, maybe a lighter throw?
I don't know.
What?
Maybe like this?
No.
Okay.
Oh, higher.
Maybe if I do higher.
Okay.
That's too high.
Maybe if I do just a little higher.
Other angle?
There's more...
All right.
Let's see.
How do I do on the other angle?
Like this?
No?
Okay.
What?
Maybe like this?
Oh!
Okay.
I got two.
Oh!
I think I got it!
No.
Okay.
No?
Oh.
Okay.
No.
I made it too complicated.
I made it too...
I don't know.
I thought we were playing with angles.
I thought we were trying to be fucking smart here.
I didn't realize it was a simple solution.
All right.
Let's see.
Let's do it here.
Oh!
It's the...
That's fucking right.
You can't give me nightmares if I don't believe in them.
Oh shit.
Wait.
Is that the...
Oh!
Those are the wizards.
What am I doing?
What did I do?
I can't tell!
I can't see!
I don't know what I did!
All right.
Nice.
Oh!
There's more.
Can't catch me?
Oh!
Never mind.
He caught me.
He fucking caught me.
Oh shit!
Okay.
It's fine.
Oh!
It's not fine!
Wait.
Little do I know, it was not fine.
It's okay.
Heals.
We got the heals.
All right.
Oh!
New update.
They're much easier to kill when grounded.
Tripping them up seems to work pretty well.
Okay I need some vases to break.
Okay.
So, there is a plant!
I'm masterfully done checking every other angle besides the correct one.
Thank you for the super chat!
Zia!
Thank you!
I was just showing you guys what not to do, chat.
Okay?
This is a walk-through.
I'm making sure you guys know what were the incorrect angles to look at, so you don't waste your time.
I am so... I'm so...
Oh my god, I am like so kind and humble.
I am giving up my own time to show you guys the wrong ways of getting these enchanted plants.
I'm giving up my own free time just for this, guys.
Yeah, I'm so considerate, chat.
How the fuck do I open you?
Where's the... where's the... where are the plants?
Where the fuck are the plants?
Oh.
Boy, read!
Keep safe the line.
Didn't do a very good job.
Oh.
Where the fuck are the plants?
Boy, look.
Where the plants at, boy?
Where is the plants?
Is the plants here?
The plants here?
Okay.
Up?
I'm gonna go up then.
Oh, it's over here!
Nice.
Oh.
Oh?
There's more?
Where are the other plants?
Huh?
Oh, here!
Okay.
There's more than two?
Where the third plant go?
Where the fuck is the third one?
I only see two.
Oh.
Wherever it was.
I got it.
First try.
I don't know where that third plant was, but I did it.
It was there somewhere.
It was... it was there.
All right.
Oh, nice.
Bitch.
Okay.
Let's go.
Oh, she's a badass.
Favouring.
There we go.
It's the possibility of the monster.
I got it.
Bitch.
Macho.
Macho!
The elves are not winning the war.
I don't know why.
I don't know.
It's just a feeling I have that they might not be winning this light vs dark elves war.
What are they doing?
Where are they running to?
Is he okay?
Do you think that light elf is gonna live?
Oh yeah!
What is he doing?
What?
Oh shit!
Why didn't he defend himself?
Is he dumb?
Oh shit!
Why didn't he fight back?
Is he stupid?
He's still alive!
He's still moving!
Holy shit!
He doesn't die!
Wait, they're still going at it!
I mean, he's still... How much HP does this guy have?
I don't...
Guys, I think... Bro!
What's his HP?
Like a million HP?
How the fuck did they lose this war?
Nope, he's still alive.
He's still struggling.
Alright.
Is he still alive?
No, yep!
Oh, okay, he's...
Oh!
Woah!
He flung him all the way over there!
Holy shit!
Damn!
He actually flung him all the...
Oh my god, they flung his fucking dead body all the way over there too!
That's fucked!
That's actually fucked!
Oh shit!
Alright.
Alright, don't worry, I got you.
Oh!
There's...
There's a reinforcements!
No!
Not this guy!
Wrong guy!
We need to get the reinforcements guy!
Oh!
Okay.
Don't worry.
Oh!
Worry!
I've tried so hard!
No!
I can't see!
There's so many!
Okay.
Don't worry, we're fine.
We're fine.
Everything is fine.
Everything is so fine.
Oh god!
Everything is still so fine!
No!
Get down!
Get down, Mr. President!
We're okay.
See I told you guys!
Everything is still fine.
Look for a way inside.
Oh, hey!
That elf body is gone.
I think my favorite part was when they flung that body all the way here.
After I finally got there.
They're like, why won't you fucking die?!
Alright.
Time to destroy the environment.
Nice.
Maybe I should upgrade the boy.
Nah.
If I upgrade him, how will he learn?
I'm not giving no hands up to my boy.
He's gotta learn just like how I did.
Let's see.
This way.
Oh, where?
Oh, there.
Goodbye.
That was easy.
Alright.
Oh, whoops.
Easy.
What the fuck?
He didn't even do anything!
The boy literally just watched.
I missed the door.
Oh shit, wait.
Wait, is that the reinforcement guy again?
Oh god, I gotta kill him before he gets reinforcements again.
Oh shit!
Oh, I fucked up!
I keep forgetting not to...
I keep wanting to hit explosions.
I can't help it.
It's okay, I'm angry.
I have anger issue.
And the wife told me to get therapy.
I knew therapy doesn't work.
Guys, that was a joke, guys.
Wait, I died?
No!
Okay, maybe I should go get anger management.
Maybe the wife was right, boy.
Wait, did I win?
Wait, where am I?
Maybe... maybe the wife was right.
Oh.
Wait, oh, I have to do this again.
God damn it!
It's alright.
I like destroying this... I like destroying Elf World.
Okay.
Back out of we go.
Wait!
No, okay.
Okay, I thought like...
I thought... wait.
Is this new?
Wait, this is new.
Wait.
I made it.
I was like, I don't remember going up.
Oh!
Yeah, it doesn't matter.
I fucking knew it.
The wife was wrong, that's why she's dead.
I've never been here.
It still worked.
The wife was wrong.
This is why she died and I lived.
See, I wanna know...
Okay, I do have to angle it.
Alright.
What's the right angle?
Did I do it?
Oh.
Alright.
Okay, nope.
I think it's right here.
Is it?
Yeah.
Alright, and then... this angle.
All I'm saying...
I died, but yet I survived.
I still got the checkpoint.
Nice.
Alright.
Uh...
I think that's everything.
Is this everything, boy?
Yeah.
Oh, shit!
Face!
I died, but I still won.
Exactly.
What the fuck is that?
How did they die between the walls?
Wait, what?
Who the fuck killed you guys there?
Hello?
Did you hear that?
Oh, they're like wasps.
Oh, the light elves are like bees!
And then the dark elves are like wasps.
How do you think we get it into the Bifrost?
The witch said to step into it.
She did?
When she was ripped away from this realm.
Yeah, this is like a wasp nest.
That's what it reminds me of.
Oh!
They're in my wasp.
Why?
Wait, it's that easy?
I just need to stab them in the head?
The fuck am I...
Why did I make it harder for myself?
Why am I stabbing them everywhere but the head?
God damn.
I just want to fight.
Good job, boy.
All right.
This way.
Oh, shit.
I guess the walls are made of Al's.
Hello?
Where's the wasp queen?
Another one!
Stay back.
Oh!
Stab him in the head!
All right, let me not do that.
Let me...
I could let go right now.
Yes, we are near our goal.
And we must be careful.
Understand?
No.
Why do we need to come out of this place?
Did he just let him live?
Oh wait, what?
Did he just like, alright, bye.
What if I just...
What if I...
Oh, the game won't let me throw up.
The game knows.
Like, what if I just throw my axe into the air.
But like, what if guys...
What if I want to throw my axe into the pile of airs?
Intrusive thought denied.
I can't believe they Doki-proofed it.
Oh shit.
Watch this.
Oh, not that.
Okay, now...
Okay, everything's fine now.
Now watch this.
Oh shit!
It's okay, we're fine.
Wait, where's my axe?
Wait, when did I fucking throw my axe away?
If I just run straight, wait.
I don't have to kill them, right?
I just need to run straight.
Okay, goodbye.
Oh shit!
Nevermind, there's too many!
Oh, there's too many!
Okay, but what if?
Goodbye.
Please let me through!
Let me through!
I just wanna know!
Fuck you!
Oh my god.
Guys, I think I should have killed him.
Alright.
If I can't run through them, I will fight them!
That's fucking...
Oh, I get XP!
Nevermind.
I will fight them.
I actually get XP.
It's okay, everything is fine.
Alright.
We're fine!
They're like grunts!
They were not meant to fight!
Alright.
Oh, he was right there.
He was literally right there.
I thought I could cheese it and just ran through it.
This is your time!
I just wanna be cheeky!
I wanna fucking run through!
They're like little babies.
They haven't grown to be adults yet.
Touch the light!
Touch it!
What if I push him in?
Oh, I destroyed the whole hive!
It's making the whole temple reappear!
It's the source of all of it!
Hold towards the light, boy!
Wait!
It's...
It's singing!
Come on, boy!
I hear her!
I told you I heard her!
Do you think she's in there?
Oh, shit!
Fucking idiot!
This is why you don't touch the light!
Hahaha!
Are you stupid?
It's like those types of dads that make you do the wrong thing to teach you a lesson.
Oh, I'm going towards the light?
Oh!
Owie!
If I punch the light hard enough...
Hahaha!
It can't hurt me!
Oh, wait!
Oh!
I told you!
Hahaha!
I fucking knew it!
It can't hurt me if I punch the light!
I'm gonna fist the light.
Oh, is that my dead wife?
Hello?
You have to come back.
You left me here alone.
Atreus?
Who?
Oh, I should follow...
What if I don't follow the light?
What happens?
What if there's loot in the light?
He's never here.
He always...
As I walk away from...
I don't...
I don't understand.
There might be loot in the light world.
It could be loot.
Alright.
Fine, fine.
I'll follow the light.
The solution to all problems.
Hit it harder.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
You don't know that?
Oh, my God.
There's a fucking crow.
God damn it!
I knew I should have given Atreus my...
axe.
The government spies are watching me again.
Alright.
Off I go.
Wait, there's so many government spies.
This is where our taxes are going to?
As a god, do I have to pay taxes?
Alright.
Knock, knock.
Oh, that's him talking to my wife.
I'm not what he thinks I am.
I know better.
Oh, that's Thor?
He doesn't talk to me.
He doesn't teach me.
Jesus Christ, stop trauma dumping, aren't you?
Him, not you.
Those are his inner thoughts.
Oh, my God, you piece of shit son.
Now I know how you really feel about me.
Fucking knew I should have pushed him into the light.
I fucking knew it.
Now I know everything, boy.
Alright.
Oh, what's this?
Oh, those are dead fish.
Am I like in Atreus' mind or something?
Alright.
Off we go.
Boy, when I get out of the light.
Oh, beat your ass.
I just wish he was better.
Damn!
I know he can be again.
I'll never change.
You wanna know what happened to my first child?
I'll try.
But if he doesn't, please come back.
I know you're out there somewhere.
Bitch.
Gods don't change.
We're too powerful.
Alright.
Up we go.
I'm literally god of war, not fucking god of fathers.
Wait, that's Faye.
What have you done?
Why did you do that?
I saved you.
You were trapped in there.
I waited and I waited but you wouldn't come out.
It was five minutes, Atreus.
I was gone only.
I was gone for five minutes.
Wait.
This doesn't look like five minutes.
You've been gone a long time.
Wait a minute.
I didn't know what to do.
You left me here.
Again.
Why don't you care?
That's impossible.
We should go before they come.
Wait, you can do this?
Why the fuck am I beating these people up?
Wait, maybe I should upgrade the boy.
Yes.
Okay, but what if I go back in?
But there's no way to get back in.
What if...
What if I just go back in though?
What if we both go in?
Boy, we can live in this happy world forever.
Your dead mom is alive in there.
That's all I'm saying.
Boy, your bow.
Hold it out.
Wait, what's this?
What the fuck is this?
I'm accepting for who he is!
A pussy!
You have acquired light arrows.
Shoot them at light crystals to infuse them.
Oh my god!
I'm letting him do what he's passionate about!
Alright.
See, I'm getting past my prejudice and letting him use elf magic.
There we go.
We did it.
I'm a good dad.
I accept him for who he is.
Little bitch.
Alright, let's go.
It's not the way to go?
Where the fuck is the other way?
Oh, it's down here.
Alright.
I'm so supportive!
I might not understand it.
I might not understand him and his interests, but I accept him.
That's all.
That's all that matters, guys.
Best parent.
You know what?
Oh my god, he should have magic now!
Okay.
Light arrows increases light arrows inflict- Oh, I like that!
We need more stun damage.
Alright, nice.
Okay.
Wait, does that mean like he can do that?
Wait, how does he shoot in it?
Okay.
Nope.
That's not how it works.
I don't know.
I thought that was how it works.
Oh, okay.
I need to put the- Oh!
Way to break the Asian parent style.
I swear, thank you for the super super chat, too.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I may or may not approve his choices, but I'm here to support you.
Alright, nice.
I broke the cycle.
Oh, again.
Wait, yeah.
That's the same attachment thing.
Okay, let's see.
Can I take the crystal away?
Alright.
See?
Boy, you can be a magician if you want.
Alright, let's see.
The cycle is broken.
Alright.
Phew!
Okay.
Where does this take me?
Okay, but like, can I shoot that?
Oh!
Okay.
That was like, I went in advance.
Alright.
We go this way.
And then...
Oh!
Oh.
Is it all light?
Oh, it's all light.
Okay.
That's interesting.
It was all light.
Oh!
Okay, there is... Oh, shit!
Go, boy, go!
Use your...
Use your magic arrows.
You may never learn.
You may never have muscles, but that's okay.
I sort of figured out you will never have muscles.
Oh, I have an axe.
This is how you actually kill them.
I had a feeling you will never have muscles, boy.
Clearly you got your mother's genes and not my genes.
Alright.
Let's see.
Oh, wait.
What's this?
Oh, loot!
Oh, no.
Not loot.
They're just dead.
Oops.
Alright.
Nice.
Okay.
Wait, what?
Oh.
Okay.
Don't worry.
Wait.
What?
Oh!
That!
Pew!
Where is the other guy?
I don't want to walk over there.
I'm like...
Alright, boy.
Do your thing.
Get closer.
Oh, my God.
He is so far.
That's fine.
If he doesn't want to get closer, that's fine by me.
Like...
Pew!
I mean, that's on him.
It's his fault for not getting closer.
Wait.
If I just upgrade, boy, do I never have to fight again?
Hmm.
Hahahaha!
Alright.
Actually...
Let's see.
Alright.
Yeah.
I figured it out.
Hmm.
Let us make our way back up.
What do you mean?
Let me find an angle.
I fucking...
It's just one shot.
What are you looking at?
Oh.
That.
Okay.
Wait, but what's over there then?
Oh, it just goes back.
Wait, what did I do?
Why would I need to go back?
I guess it's a shortcut?
Alright.
Nice.
Guys, why did you not tell me?
Guys, look.
After accepting my boy for what he is, I now...
Now I realize that he is gonna grow up and take care of me.
Now that I've accepted him for who he is.
Look at that.
That's character development right there.
Hahaha.
Defy your arrows!
Defying it!
Hahaha.
Now he'll...
Now he'll have to take care of me.
Oh shit!
You're free!
Okay.
I realize I fought the wrong guy.
This is the guy that's important.
Alright.
Alright, nice.
Now he won't put me in the home.
Alright, let's see.
Grab that.
To upgrade...
Oh, wait.
No, I already upgraded it.
What am I supposed to shoot at?
Oh shit.
I'm lost.
Where am I?
Do I go up here?
Oh, I go up here!
Retirement saved!
Alright.
This should be it.
Right?
Oh, it's not.
Wait, is that the...
Reinforcement guy?
Come on, shoot him!
Shoot him!
Keep shooting him!
Oh shit!
That's fucking right.
My boy knows magic!
I don't know what to...
I still don't understand what it is, but if he enjoys it, that's all that matters, right?
Dude!
Wait, where did he go?
Chest time.
Psycho's not broken.
Alright, nice.
Not go there?
Does light magic versus light magic not work against each other?
Okay...
Where the fuck do I go?
Uh...
Oh.
This.
There you go.
And then we put the crystal.
Gamers don't look up.
Boop!
Light it?
Light it.
Read!
Boy.
It's reading time.
Oh shit, it's gone.
Did you read it in time?
Okay, don't tell...
Oh, just write in your fancy little book and not tell your father.
Alright, from the light we are born into the light we...
I'm just gonna read your fucking diary, I guess.
God, I gave this...
I let this boy learn magic, and this is how he repays me?
Wait.
That's fucked.
And a sand bowl.
But how do you expect me to reach it?
Wait, what?
Oh shit, I'm going at his back door.
Alright.
I'm gonna steal this.
So unclaimed.
I told you guys, I only have eyes for one door.
And one door only.
You gonna carry that everywhere?
I just might.
I told you.
Alright, let's see.
Alright.
Is there anything else I'm missing?
What's up here?
Wait, what is up here?
Oh, chest!
Okay.
Uh...
Whoop.
Wait, where's the third one?
Oh no, I don't know where the third one is.
Oh, it's right here!
Okay, one...
Two...
Three.
Nice.
I need to figure out how to get there.
Oh.
That's how.
Alright, easy.
So fucking easy.
Up I go.
Wait.
I hear, like, nature.
Alright.
I hear an animal that's not extinct yet.
Wait.
This way.
Okay.
Damn!
I might have supported you, but I still don't respect you.
Oh!
Hahaha!
Alright, let's see.
Uh...
Go this way.
And then...
Oh!
Oh, there's some...
Oh, there's plants here.
Okay...
Oh, is this the angle?
No.
Wait, what's the angle?
Oh shit.
Okay, maybe up here?
Alright.
We've been standing here a while.
What the fuck do I...
Oh, this way.
Okay.
Pew!
Nice.
Okay, and I came from this direction.
So...
I gotta...
Wait, what did I do?
Oh, this...
This is what I did.
Hahaha!
Sorry.
I was like, what the fuck did I do again?
Alright.
Put this here.
Hey, baby door.
I told you I wouldn't...
I told you I'll be back.
Back door, I see.
Hahaha!
Nice.
Alright.
How do I get there?
What the fuck?
Uh...
How do I get there?
Oh!
Okay.
Oh, dear!
Get up.
Oh,
I know what I have to do now.
Hahaha!
Oh, that's all it needed.
It just needed to see.
Hahaha!
Hey, baby door.
I'm here to give you what you want.
Hahaha!
Oh!
And it opened!
Hahaha!
I told you guys!
And then...
And then the door gave birth to light elves.
It was that easy.
It was that easy!
Hahaha!
Oh my god!
And then the light elves came out.
The light elves are back!
We freed the light of Elfhelm from whatever dark elves were doing to it, and they all returned to the temple.
Everything is beautiful in Elfhelm.
Now that the light shines free, the light elves seem nice.
They don't really say anything, but at least they aren't trying to kill us.
Father says I shouldn't assume anything, but what does he know?
He was doing who knows what inside the light...
Hahaha!
Father kept touching the door.
And then the light elves came.
Hahaha!
But I had to take down an entire swarm of dark elves by myself.
I don't care what he says.
I'm glad we got involved.
I saved them!
I...
Oh!
My controller, do you see there?
Oh shit!
What?
What does he want now?
Yeah, what does he want?
Is he mad?
He's very mad.
Why he mad?
What did I do?
I just... I was just comforting the door.
Hahaha!
I took you seriously out here saving a species.
I told you guys.
My eyes are only for one door and one door only.
You took his door.
That door didn't even love him.
I bet like... I bet that door didn't even let him use the back entrance.
What do we have to do?
We really gotta go back down here again?
Oh, this is the...
Is this the fast pass?
Oh.
Okay.
I guess we go back this way, I guess.
Down... we...
go...
Oh, wait, no, we do go this way.
What?
We actually go through here?
What the fuck?
How do I access?
Oh.
This.
Yippee!
I can't believe the rune red seed.
The joke's right itself.
I don't even need to try to be a content creator.
It just falls right into my lap.
Okay, nice.
Spoilers of war.
Oh, shit, nice.
Give me the loot.
The war is over, so I can rob some more graves.
Wonder if I could, like...
There isn't a way back up from here, you know.
I know.
Anything out here?
Alright.
I guess we go this way.
Pew!
Whoa!
There's rain here?
I thought we won the war!
How the f- Whoa!
Pew!
Oh, wait, my knife.
My gun.
Pew!
Oh, wait.
Wait, where did he go?
There we go.
Nice.
And then I need you to hit that.
Is there anything behind us?
Oh, there's another witch.
You know what?
Fuck you.
I'm gonna go up close and personal.
That's fucking right.
That's fucking right!
You think you can get away from me?
What you gonna do with your goddamn magic?
Nothing!
Yeah!
Melee always better than an archery.
How are we supposed to get across without a crystal?
Oh, I need a crystal.
Alright, we gotta find a crystal.
I guess it'll be over here.
Oh...
Oh!
There's a crystal.
So hard to see cause it's like black and white.
Oh, get out of here.
Get the fuck out of here.
My boy knows magic.
That's fucking right.
The same magic that kept you locked in!
Alright.
Oh, you're still alive?
I wish you would have been dead earlier.
Is there any loot in there?
No.
Oh, nice.
Thank god you're dead.
Yay!
Spoilers of war.
And then...
Vases!
Goodbye.
And I'm full HP too.
Alright.
Time to put the crystal down.
Let's go.
Let's see.
You know, sometimes I wonder if this is even my boy.
Like, does he even have anything that's related to me?
Like, where are his muscles?
Where the fuck are your muscles, boy?
What?
Okay.
Oh, nice.
Wait.
Okay, nevermind.
Just shoot him.
I'm not putting down my...
Go, boy, go!
You got this, boy!
That's fucking right!
You got this!
He's almost dead!
It's like Pokemon!
You can do this, boy!
Where are his muscles?
Where are his abs?
How do I even know that's my boy?
I know Greek and Norse mythology.
He banged everything.
The only guy that, like, actually practiced, like...
Oh, shit, boy!
You got this!
Okay, we did it.
I did it.
The only guy that actually, like, was faithful to his wife was Hades.
So, like, how...
I don't know.
I don't even know if, like, in Norse mythology, if any of them were ever faithful.
Alright.
Nice.
Alright, nice.
Hades locked her...
Hades kidnapped her?
Yeah, but, like...
But he was faithful to her!
He didn't bang another woman!
He might be kidnapped, but, like...
That was the one woman for him!
Okay...
Am I supposed to go this way?
Oh, wait, no.
I'd be going backwards.
JK!
I'm supposed to go this way.
Ummm...
Almost!
Doesn't mean he did!
Okay, I don't need the health, but I just did it as, like, intimidation.
Whoa!
Oh, get out!
Get out!
No touchy!
Six feet!
Pew!
Oh!
Oh, shit!
That's right, I'm angry now!
That's fucking right!
Double team!
I'm gonna double team!
That's right, what are you gonna do now?
Fucking fly?
Wait.
Oh, shit.
Okay.
Wait, wait, wait.
Wait, he did fly!
That's fucked!
I can't believe he actually used his wings!
That should be illegal!
Oh, oh, oh no!
Okay, where is he?
Where is he?
Okay.
Get down!
Oh!
That's fucking right, I'm gonna swing now!
Oh no, where did he go?
Where did he go?
That's fucking right.
Alright.
Where did he go?
That's okay, the boy knows where he went!
Okay.
Get down from here!
Get down!
Oh, I parried!
I told you I know how to parry!
Oh, where did he go?
Huh?
Oh!
What the fuck?
Where did he go?
Yeah, not so tough now!
Oh!
I can't see him!
Boy, you know where he is, right?
Oh!
That's fucking right!
Nice!
One more hit!
You know what, boy?
I'll give you the pleasure!
I'll give you the pleasure of beating him like Pokemon!
I think...
Is he shooting him?
You got this, boy!
Oh, finisher!
Boy has better eyesight!
Nice!
Where's your queen now?
I see you're out!
No, that can't be!
What did it say?
That we made a grave mistake!
Huh?
Wait...
Are the night elves?
Let me guess...
You're gonna be smug and say you told me we shouldn't get involved!
That is enough!
Here we go now!
Wait...
A wolf?!
Sorry!
We don't care about that!
I got it!
I got a wolf powers now!
Who cares?
Someone died!
Oh my god!
Sorry, what did he say?
Who cares?
Now we have dog powers!
Alright, nice!
We helped the wrong side?
But how?
They're ugly!
But the night elves!
They're beautiful!
And the night elves!
They're ugly!
What do you mean?
Do you remember the answer?
Yeah, yeah.
Is it seed?
What's that?
Boy, read this!
Boy, what's that say?
Well, I'm sorry!
I worked my entire life to send you to fucking college!
The only time you cared to talk to me I didn't get the answer!
You don't get the education that you have!
If your mother was still alive, we would not be here at all!
I work all day to pay for your tuition!
Forget it!
And you can't fucking read for me?
I let you learn the pussy magic, shit!
I might not understand it but I supported it!
You see these bare hands?
That's your dead half sister!
That could have been you!
Alright, this is it.
Alright, let's see.
We gotta go this way!
How dare you!
We made you!
You came for my falls!
It's not my fault I failed a quick time event.
That's fucking right.
Damn.
Oh shit!
Is there more?
I feel like I already explored everything from here.
Did I actually help the round?
It's sad the elves can't work things out.
I'll find such a beautiful place, but war makes it ugly.
Like how could they?
You see in the eyes of a child.
In war, a soldier sees beauty only in the blood of his enemy.
The rest of him is lost, sometimes never to return.
You know about war, don't you?
I'm literally a god of war.
Sis!
Battles may be won by the better soldier.
Wars are won by those who are worse.
I'm willing to sacrifice everything to ensure victory.
Yeah, they attacked me first.
It's self-defense.
What's this?
Touch it.
We don't know what it is, so touch it.
Oh nice!
Having lasting benefits.
Oh!
Epic!
Uh... cooldown permanently increases by two.
Nice.
Did we eat it?
Yoink.
Like, how could the light elves be bad?
They don't even attack.
They literally can't even fight back.
Alright, let's see.
Is there anything?
Oh, hey there.
Alright.
Do I have any upgrades?
There's an abandoned temple in Midgard that a fellow dwarf converted to his personal storage.
Oh, in Midgard?
At Earth!
Packed it with all sorts of treasures he collected during his travels throughout the realms.
Throughout the realms?
Which ones did he go to?
What did he collect?
Fafnir was a, shall we say, aggressive collector of magical artifacts.
The more he acquired, the more he desired.
There was no realm too dangerous, no relic too hazardous.
He once ventured deep into Niflheim for a whetstone of all things.
Huh.
I bet that was quite the whetstone.
I guess I was like, the light elves are like super racist.
I told you guys.
You guys judge my prejudice.
But I...
If I was racist towards the elves first, they can't be racist to me.
Alright, we gotta find that.
Okay.
Let's see.
You have some lost items?
That you left behind.
Select the lost items.
Oh!
I'll claim it.
Yeah!
Sorry.
No.
No need to be sorry.
Let's see.
Can I upgrade my axe?
Oh, I should upgrade your... Oh...
We don't have any of that.
Oh!
Alright, let's reduce your recharge time.
Let's see.
Do I have this equipped yet?
No.
Okay.
Let's see.
We start around...
Oh, I'm poor.
I don't have... I can't afford anything.
I'm so poor right now.
Wait.
Was that 25k?
Holy shit!
That was 25k!
Boy, you better fucking clutch this for me.
I doesn't need... I...
You guys know I don't read.
Oh!
That's 4 damage...
Oh, I already upgraded it.
Okay.
Oh!
That's 3 damage!
Okay.
Hold L1 and R2.
What does this do?
Unlocks an additional fallout attack.
Okay, I think I'm gonna do this.
And then...
Alright.
That should be good.
Oh, that's just cosmetics.
Oh, and then you'll have wolf power.
I like that.
I like wolf power.
Do I have like...
Minus 11?
Ew.
Do I have anything better?
Minus 8?
But then I do have plus 12 runic.
Uh...
You know what?
Bye.
I'll try it.
I'll try it out.
It's level 2 anyway.
Oh, wait!
It is level 2!
Okay.
Oh, but I get rid of a rune.
That's bad.
Oh, well.
Okay.
Boy...
Do you get any...
Oh, it's just...
Do you even...
Enemies choked will take increased damage.
Oh, I like that!
I like increased damage.
Okay, can I afford anything?
Uh...
Purchase, purchase, purchase.
Oh, you're fully upgraded.
Okay, I guess I should grab some stuff too.
Perform attacks without sustaining inflict...
Oh!
I like that.
Okay, that's a good upgrade.
Faye, our boy is a furry now.
I accept him now!
You don't understand, Faye.
He can summon wolves!
You don't understand!
He has wolf power, Faye!
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I understand.
How is he evil?
How are they the evil ones?
They don't even self-defend themselves.
They're, like, weak as fuck.
Like, I don't see dead fucking...
I don't see dead dark elves.
All I see is dead light elves.
All right.
Let's see.
Let's go this way.
Magic's dumb, but wolf magic, that's different, chat.
Wolf magic is different.
Father, I have a confession to make.
Oh, no.
What is it?
All those voices in my head.
Well...
There's more?
This is my first time.
Back when we met Brock, his animal warned me about something hiding in the trees.
That's why she didn't want to cross.
She told you.
Well, I could just feel what she was feeling.
What she was afraid of.
Hmm.
It happens again.
You tell me.
Understand?
Oh, I never looted this.
How is wolf magic different?
Because they're good boys.
They're good boys.
Oh, hey, loot.
What does it say?
It's about the eternal war for the light.
Do you think it'll stop now after what we did?
Unlikely.
Oh, so they'll still fight.
Okay.
So...
We gave no impact in this fight.
We gave no impact in this war.
Cool.
Maybe the dark elves were...
Maybe the dark elves were like...
Were like servants or slaves or something.
They like kept them as like...
Because they saw them as lesser.
That's why they didn't fight back.
Because they're like...
You're beneath...
I'd rather die than touch you.
That's so fucked.
Holy shit.
Maybe that's why.
I wish mom were here.
The light elves were like...
You know what?
I'd rather die...
Than like...
Than like let you...
Than let you guys...
Than fight back.
Damn.
Elves are fucked.
This is why...
This is exactly why I told you not to practice elf magic, boy.
Elves are fucked, man.
All right.
Let's see.
Where do we go?
I guess this way?
We have the light.
To Midgard.
Okay.
All right.
Let's see.
The dwarves were right.
There was a reason why dwarves hated elves.
They were right.
Midgard.
Okay.
No.
That's Elfman.
That's Yodahem.
That's Vanahem.
That's...
Okay.
There's so many Hems.
That's Nif-Hem.
There's Asgard.
There's...
Okay.
I don't know.
I went the wrong way.
Wait.
Where's Midgard's...
Goddamn.
Where's Midgard's center?
I didn't...
I was like, what are those tiny characters on my right hand side?
That's not important, right?
There we go.
We figured it out.
Sorry.
I didn't turn my head.
I saw like tiny letters and I was like, tiny letters does not mean it's important.
All right.
Let's see.
Okay.
We did it.
Where would the light go?
Uh...
Here?
And the God of War said, let there be light.
Oh, he's back.
We just came back from another realm and we met your brother.
Wait, not that order.
Did you like...
Did you know that that seed saw put hand to your blade?
No.
You do know he lost his talent.
Wait, what?
Just up and left him one day.
Tried taking me down with him.
Is that why you're...
He's not blue?
Quite the opposite.
You're leaving a blind pig farts up a truffle now and again.
What if like the else things is like the French Revolution and I basically stopped it?
Oh no, I stopped the French Revolution.
It's better.
Good.
Now when you're done gawking, I got a favor to ask.
Oh, there's a mission.
What is it, dwarf?
There's this alchemist on Vary.
Been working out in the Velander mines.
You haven't heard from him and made him a friend.
Maybe, I don't know, a hundred winters or so.
Probably did, but maybe you can find him.
He's dwarfing like me.
No guillotine, no French.
I am the guillotine, that's it.
But I missed and chopped the wrong head.
If you find Don Vary, I'll make him whip you up something special.
Alright.
He's a century stone here.
I ought to get you inside those mines.
Okay, we got a...
I mean, that's just a choice.
Alright, let's see.
God, I'm so poor.
I should start selling my stuff, actually.
Uh...
Where...
These are things I'm not wearing, right?
I'm not wearing any of these?
Can't tell.
Oh!
Oh, they have no other use on my journey.
Okay.
Sell your toys.
They have no other use.
Okay.
You got what you wanted.
They have no other use on your journey.
No other use?
It has no other use.
Okay!
Let me sell them.
Nice.
Okay, we gotta sell this and we gotta sell this.
Okay.
That means I should have enough to upgrade my stuff?
Uh...
Ooh, this one is an ancient heart.
Mmm...
I'd rather like save up for the...
I want to save up.
I'm gonna save up for this.
I don't wanna... I don't wanna buy any of this.
I'm gonna save up.
Okay.
Alright, we just need to find... we need to find...
I'm not struggling anyway.
Yeah.
I don't even know what the Ancients are.
You have better armor?
I'm not even struggling.
That's the thing.
Is it worth it?
I don't know if it's worth it.
I feel like I'm not struggling at all so that I don't care about these armors anyway.
Oh!
It's the Golems?
Okay.
I guess I could get this.
I'll just buy this.
Awww.
Awww!
And it's not a shirt so like... I love it.
Don't?
Okay.
Let's see.
What armor am I wearing though?
Like what am I wearing?
I just don't wanna wear a shirt.
I wanna free the nipple.
I need them to see that I'm buff.
Like I worked so hard.
Look at this.
I worked so... Oh.
I worked so hard for this body.
We need to walk across the bridge to the Vanaheim Tower.
Are we going to the Black Breath?
Or exploring?
Your choice.
We're going straight... straight forward.
That's what the yellow hand parade is telling us.
And what's this?
What?
I can go higher?
What's this for?
What is this?
Yeah, what is this?
A horn?
Can we blow into it?
Without knowing the outcome?
Yeah!
I'll usually push every button.
Pull every lever...
I literally pushed this button.
I don't know if we can predict.
No.
This is something else.
We must develop your instincts.
What is that?
Wait.
I knew it.
We are blowing the horn.
No.
This is something else.
I cannot blow the horn.
I wanna blow the horn.
God damn it.
No fun.
No fucking fun.
Only one bird is allowed here.
Stupid bird.
Oh, wait.
There's a...
There's a guy.
But there's a bird.
No, my coffee!
No, you guys don't understand.
That bird was more important.
You guys don't understand.
Alright.
It's time to beat that guy up.
That's fucking right.
You thought I don't block?
After learning about my son and his passion, I too have learned some new moves.
Told you.
Even God of Wars can learn new things.
Nice.
God damn it.
When have you...
When can you read?
Okay.
I'll get this.
Alright.
What's more terrifying than a dragger?
A dragger that can run at you really fast?
They were running?
Okay.
Well, they died before they can.
Uh, return to the mountain.
Where the fuck is the mountain?
Oh, look.
The witch's magic is still covering those scorn poles.
Oh, nice.
It saves us some time.
We can just run past everything.
Emma, thank you for...
Welcome to the tomato farm.
Welcome.
Oh!
Does that mean you shoot that now?
Never mind.
No, you're still useless in some way.
Alright.
I guess we go this way.
Never mind.
Alright.
Down we go.
Okay.
Let's go.
This way.
Yeah, I need a crystal.
There's no crystal here.
Okay.
I hear a crow.
I know you're here.
I fucking know you're here.
I heard you.
I heard the drone.
There's a fine line between ambition and greed, you know.
Where the fuck is the drone?
I know you're here.
You can't find me!
I thought you can summon wolves!
Where are the wolves!
I gave you wolf power!
Oh shit!
What's the point of giving you wolf power if you don't even use it?
If I had wolf power, I would spam that every day.
Alright, I have to hold down the boy button?!
Fucking boy!
Alright, where's the crow?
Where's the drone?
Where's the government drone?
The fuck is it?
I heard you!
Is that it?
No, that's just a regular bird.
I know you're alive.
Where's this magic coming from?
What?
Okay, there is magic here, but I don't know where it is.
Where the fuck is the magic?!
You're over here!
I know you're over here!
No, that's just a regular crow!
God damn it!
Wait, what's that?
What the fuck is that?
Wait, oh!
Oh shit!
Okay, that's badass!
That's actually badass, not gonna lie.
God damn it, boy.
Wait, then how?
What happened to that?
Does it die to poison?
Is it dying?
No, it's not.
Use your magic woes!
What's the point if you can't use your magic woes?
Oh shit!
Oops.
I walked into it.
That was on me, guys.
Okay, that was badass, though.
The magic woes.
That shit looks so cool.
I gave up.
I don't know where the fuck the crow is.
I guess Odin can have a little peep show.
I've given up.
It's very easy for me to give up.
Where the fuck is the thing?
Okay.
I don't know.
Awe.
Wait, where did Boy- Wait, wait, where is he?
Okay.
Oh, there you are!
I was like, where did he go?
Wait, where did he go?
Where did he go?
So, who do you think carved the face in the mountain?
You would know better than I.
Oh?
What's that sound?
Okay, I can't burn that yet.
I don't have fire powers, apparently.
Alright, off we go!
We're off to see the witch.
We're off to see the wizard.
The wonderful wizard of Oz.
And God of War said, let there be light!
Be gone!
Okay, but what if...
What happens if we go into the darkness?
What happens?
What if I want to go into the darkness?
I want to let the darkness into my heart.
You become Kingdom Hearts.
Jesus Christ, this is so loud.
What the fuck is that?
Is that also something that's related?
The vibrating crystals?
Alright.
Off we go!
Jesus!
Why can't I run?
Woo!
The light of...
Then we climb.
Aphelim...
Aphem.
Okay.
We gotta climb here.
Wait.
I hear it.
I hear you.
No, I'm not going crazy.
I know you exist!
I know you fucking exist!
I heard you.
It's not voices.
I know you're real.
God damn it.
Where the fuck are you?
I know you're real.
I know you're spying on me.
I hear him.
He's like right here.
He's above me.
You know...
All they said the giants used to visit the Midgard Mountains before they disappeared.
I know you're here.
Where are you?
Yeah.
But that's just a normal crow!
Perhaps they returned to their home.
There's normal crows?
Maybe.
I wonder if the...
No.
No, that's not true.
Crows aren't real.
They were invented by the government.
Why else are there so many of them?
No, that can't be.
More black breath.
Alright.
It's going to be light.
Where do I go?
I guess I follow?
I guess I go this way?
Oh, there's a skull down there.
Phew!
Okay.
There must be something over here, right?
Yeah.
Oh, shit!
Wait, there is.
Oh!
Nice loot.
Alright.
Down I go.
Down, down, down, down.
Okay.
Nice.
Alright.
Still can't open that yet.
Oh!
Wait, no.
That's like...
This is exactly like getting over it.
It almost baited me.
It...
It's like snakes and ladder where that snake takes you all the way down.
Don't go down the rope.
It's just like snakes and ladders.
Okay.
I guess we go this way.
Open the door!
Weeow!
Alright.
Wait, is that a deer?
Woah!
Wait, what kind of god is that?
What kind of god is that?
Woah!
What the fuck?!
What the fuck are you?
Okay.
That scared the shit out of me.
What the fuck?
Came out of nowhere.
That's fucking right.
You can't do jack shit.
Is there loot here?
No loot.
More stuff I can't do yet.
Fucking trees.
It's always the trees.
Always the goddamn trees.
Oh hey, loot.
Nice.
Got more money.
Money.
Wanted to beat up that box.
Breathe.
What's that mean?
Boy explain.
A second light crystal?
Two?
Oh!
Okay.
What am I supposed to do?
What?
Whatever.
Yeah, me too.
What?
Yeah.
What's happening?
Okay.
Is there another crystal?
Is there?
It's a box.
A box.
Huh?
Are you serious?
Oh, hey!
There it is!
Did I hit it?
What the fuck did I do?
I think I hit it.
It's glowing.
Is it glowing?
I think it's glowing.
Yeah.
Yeah, it's glowing.
I did it.
Huh?
Oh!
Wait, there's a crystal there too!
Huh?
How the fuck do I get to the other side?
No!
Believe in me!
There must be a way.
Go back and look up?
Oh my... Guys, if this was yellow, I would've figured it out.
All I'm saying is that if they... It's because it's blue!
And it threw me off!
It threw me off!
It was blue!
Who the fuck makes that shit blue?
Why can't it be yellow crystals?
If it was yellow crystal, I would've figured it out.
Alright.
Freedom?
What's it doing?
Huh?
What class?
Oh, I can climb now!
Oh, it's a door.
Nevermind, it's a door.
Yes, light the crystal.
Use the magic that you learned.
Okay, I don't trust these.
Never trust them.
Down is up!
I am always serious.
Okay.
Mama always said you never took an interest in history.
Giants are just a race, like elves and hold your phone.
It doesn't mean they're big.
What are the worlds of it?
Okay, in that case, giant also means big.
But there's only one of them.
Wait, what's that?
Doesn't matter, there's a vase.
Arteus.
Let's see how far you can shoot.
Did you hit it?
Okay, clearly not far enough.
Alright, up we go.
Oh shit.
Oh shit, that's a lot!
Okay.
Wait, where the fuck did my axe go?
Wait, I need to get rid of the mini guys first.
Alright, now...
Now I'm...
Oh shit!
Okay, I guess I am serious.
I did not mean to do that, but I'm serious now.
That was an accident.
But I'm serious.
There you go.
That's fucking right.
I don't fucking play around.
Oh, okay, they're all dead.
Yay!
Alright.
The summoner?
Oh, they summoned the nightmares!
I see.
Oh wait, there's so much loot!
What's that sound?
I see... I hear a creature.
That's still alive.
Okay, I gotta get rid of this.
What does this do?
Oh, it's just light.
Okay, nice.
Nice.
Okay.
I hear you.
Fucking hear you.
Don't think you can hide from me.
Don't think you can hide...
Oh!
You thought...
You thought I couldn't hear you.
That's fucking right.
I knew you were here.
Okay, this way.
Wait.
Not this way?
Where's the chest for this?
Okay, this is the right way.
So this is the extra way.
Okay.
I'm just gonna...
I'm just gonna get rid of him real fast.
Like, I don't wanna deal...
Oh!
Wait!
That's more than one!
Oh!
That guy's level four.
That guy's very strong.
Oh!
All right.
What if I send in the...
I send in the woes.
Okay, nice.
Oh, shit!
Okay.
I'm gonna grab my axe back.
Swing!
Keep swinging!
Oh!
That's okay.
I parry.
This is so low!
Oh!
He's so low!
Please!
Boy!
I fucked up Boy!
JK.
I'm a gamer.
I never fuck up.
All right.
Let's see...
Where the fuck is...
Where's the chest?
How do I get over there?
All right.
Where the fuck's the chest, though?
Oh!
Shoot this!
Does that do anything?
Oh, there's the chest!
Okay, I don't trust these at all.
It's blue.
Okay.
Wait, where's the chest?
I don't like how I can't find the chest.
Where the fuck's the chest?
Okay, this way.
Oh.
Oh, shit!
That's fucking right.
That's right!
You can't touch the ground now!
Yay!
Where's the chest though?
Okay.
This is the right way to go.
So... okay.
That lore is not important.
So, it's this way.
Oh, there it is!
Oh, I did it!
I didn't do it?
Oh!
B-N-R.
Okay.
Alright, that is...
That's the N.
Where's the B?
Oh my god, where are the other letters?
Okay.
That's N.
That is... none of that.
F-R.
Where's the last one?
Oh, there it is!
That's N.
Oh no.
Did I hit it?
I'm gonna make it hit.
Don't worry.
Oh my god.
This way.
Okay, I'll get closer.
Look, I was lazy, okay?
I just wanted it to be easy.
Okay, why is it not hitting?
Okay, F...
B.
There we go.
That should work.
Alright.
Yippee!
Trust tab!
Yay!
I wish I could take everything else in there.
I clearly needed money.
So, like, it wouldn't matter.
Holy shit, that's a big giant.
Don't trust you.
I knew I shouldn't have trusted you.
Oh, loot!
What's this?
What?
Oh shit.
And you're running back to me?
Go, Woes!
Go!
Keep using your magic, Woes!
Oh my... yeah.
Yeah, they're not...
My axe doesn't go that far, guys.
My...
I'm just gonna...
My axe does not go that far.
Oh, there we go.
Easy.
Wait.
What's the point of being here?
There was no crystals here!
How the fuck were they mad?
Whoa!
Fuck this guy in particular.
Look, they're level 4!
I had to!
Alright, nice.
There's, like, no crystals anywhere.
I guess I go down here.
Can I carry this crystal?
No.
There is a door here, right?
Oh, there is!
What the fuck?
Oh, loot.
Alright.
Oh, nice!
More loot!
Alright, we're gonna grab this.
We're so poor.
We need all the money we can get.
Where the fuck do I go?
I guess this way?
Yeah.
Okay.
I bet you I'm like only 10% done with this game.
There was like 700 worlds I could go.
We only went to one of them.
That...
It feels like I'm only 10% done with the story.
They look like regular people.
Oh, they're a trap?
Turns his entire body into liquid.
He scared me.
Gary, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Boom.
The statue!
We made it across!
We did it!
Jump!
Alright.
I like how they all triggered every single trap.
There.
And they all died.
Just for me to show up.
Okay, this is where I should be going.
So this is loot.
Yay!
Look here.
Read.
I've seen this language before.
Read, boy.
Alright.
I'll just steal your diary.
That's okay.
The serpent cannot be spoken to, but his belligerence towards the Aesir is unmistakable.
The Destruction Tires Temple is infeasible while he remains.
However, his presence has caused the Lake of Nine to submerge it completely.
Therefore, the larger aim... Alright.
You should have kept your diary locked up, boy.
Oh, hey.
More reads.
You think he's still alive?
Alright.
Open.
Oh.
Shit.
I like how I can just literally just walk to... sidestep to the left.
It's just that easy.
Holy shit.
That's so fucking dumb.
He's like, oh no, what do I do?
Alright.
Gotta make sure they're all dead.
Oh shit.
That's two.
That's right.
You thought...
You thought I couldn't count and see two?
Oh shit!
It's actually three!
JK.
I actually couldn't count and it was three.
I can't believe it was three all along.
She couldn't count.
How the fuck was I supposed to know it was three?
What a fucking plot twist.
Yeah.
That's actually fucked.
I can't believe he did that to me.
Alright.
This is clearly extra stuff.
Loot.
Loot loot.
Uh...
I guess that was it.
That was all the loot.
Alright.
Can I...
How do I get up there?
I guess here?
The God of War does not need a count.
All it needs to do is beat the shit out of people.
Or does it need counting?
Who needs to count when they're all dead?
Alright.
Up we go.
Alright, boy.
Read.
It's a name, I think.
Frazzly.
It means terror.
It's all about smash.
Weird.
There's a candle all tangled up with string and some sort of animal heart.
Some kind of lantern?
Alright, loot.
That is of no use to us.
The Bifrost lights our way.
Alright.
Yeah, we don't need light?
Hey, what do you think about these torches?
What's this?
Is this...
Eyes open.
Okay, shortcut.
Okay, nice.
We got the shortcut.
Oh.
Fuck you.
You don't need to count if they're all dead.
What's this?
Oh, shit.
Wait.
Loot?
Loot!
Okay, nice.
No kid of mine is gonna count.
I let him be a magician.
And socialize with those elves.
I'm gonna put my foot down on counting.
No, that's...
That's a little too much, boy.
Your grandpa didn't know how to count.
And your grandpa's grandpa's.
And your grandpa's grandpa's grandpa's.
I'm not gonna stop now.
You can be a magician.
But a nerd.
No.
Not a nerd.
But a nerd.
That's just too far, boy.
Go.AHHAA No boy of mine is gonna be a goddamn nerd.
So many thins...
Where the fuck do I go?
There's like... There's so many things.
What's elven magic not enough for you, boy?
What's elven magic not Oh,
shit!
What did I do?
Oh, okay.
Oh, shit!
Alright, magic time!
Alright, wolves.
Go do your thing, wolves!
Go do your thing!
Oh, shit!
That's fucking right!
I'm gonna swing!
Swing to win!
Alright, execution style.
Where's the last guy?
Oh, there he is!
That's right!
You think I'm afraid of you?
That's fucking right!
I fought the level fours!
I ain't afraid of you!
Fucking easy.
Alright, we're gonna get rid of these guys, though.
These guys need done.
Alright, nice.
Alright.
Okay.
Where did I come from?
Did I come from here?
There's too many doors.
I...
I don't know.
There's too many doors.
Where did I go?
Maybe here?
Wait, there's something here.
Oh, it's blue!
Okay, so there's... I gotta get something out from there.
What's this for?
Okay, this is nothing.
Oh!
Fucking knew it!
Can't hide from me.
Alright.
Oh!
I looked up.
Loot!
Okay.
Oh!
Words!
Read.
Boy.
Get over here.
This is why I sent you to college.
That's funny.
How so?
One hand wrote.
Jotnar only.
And another wrote.
And also doors.
What about the elves?
Oh!
No elves allowed.
We need to free the rope from under the mess you created up there, boy.
Maybe there's a way up there through that passage then.
Okay, so I have to go here.
Which means...
It could be something...
Oh!
Fucking knew it.
If there's wood I cut.
Alright.
Okay.
Can I send it up here?
Boy.
God damn it, boy.
How do I get up there?
Okay.
How the fuck do I get up there?
Boy.
Boy, what's the use if you can't climb anything?
Okay.
What's this?
Oh!
This is...
This is leaving.
Okay.
I get it.
God damn it, boy!
No elves allowed.
This is giants and dwarves territory.
We only allow dwarves and very tall people.
No mid-size.
If you're in between, you're not allowed in there.
I guess I go to the big orange hole.
Is down up?
Oh shit, I was about to...
How did you get here?
Yeah!
How did you get down here?
Oh, I guess because you're a dwarf, you know where the hidden places are.
There's traps?
Okay.
Alright,
I think you can upgrade stuff now, right?
Oh, I should get rid of the Dark Elves thing.
I don't need to worry about Dark Elves anymore.
Which one did I have it on?
It was my armor, right?
Okay, I think I... did I take it off?
Oh, I did!
Oh, I fucked up.
Okay.
Did I take it off?
I think I did, right?
Yeah, I did.
I removed it.
Okay, that's good.
Alright, that's good.
Alright, I should be able to... Oh, yeah, I could definitely...
Yeah!
Yeah, I should start upgrading my stuff.
I'm a little behind on that.
Let's see.
Yeah, that's awkward.
I already have a lot of this throwing stuff.
I'm using a lot of close combat now, so...
Well, I don't dodge, so I don't need that.
While sprinting, increase the amount...
Oh!
Like that.
While evading... While sprinting...
Okay, I don't sprint, so we definitely don't need that.
I already have that.
Hold R... Hold R to...
Ooh!
I'll perform a more...
A more powerful rage.
Okay, I don't do any of this.
Okay, shield combat.
I guess I'll do this, too.
Alright, that's fine.
Oh my god, where do I go?
When you're given too many choices.
Where does this go?
Where the fuck?
Where am I?
Oh!
Oh, loot!
Okay, nice.
Oh!
Rage.
What's this?
Oh, it's door!
Okay.
I guess I'll grab this.
Loot!
Um...
Oh!
Nice.
I need that seal for armor.
More traps.
Traps?
There's a tunnel, but...
Oh!
Break it.
Okay.
I see it now.
A trap?
It is a mountain.
Break it.
Guys, did you guys see that trap?
Yeah.
Oh!
God fucking...
Okay.
First try.
All right.
Let's go this way.
Oh!
That one guy was...
That one was sneaky.
Because he didn't say anything.
Okay, we just...
What?
Oh.
What kind of fucking trap is this?
Oh!
You okay?
I'm okay.
Heya!
Let's go!
Oh, God!
I was going back.
Oh!
That was close.
I don't know how to...
I wasn't supposed to know that was gonna happen!
Okay.
No?
Get over here!
What?
Oh shit!
Oh.
Oh shit, no!
I didn't do any upgrades on close combat!
We can't do it!
Alright.
This one I can just near you.
I'll just do that.
Can't be bothered.
No you do not, boy!
No you do not!
Huh?
Wait, there's something over there.
I guess that's where I'm supposed to go?
Wait, what the fuck is that?
Is that dead troll?
No!
What the fuck are you?
What are you?
What?
What is that?
Catch it?
How do I catch it?
What?
That's right, I'm gonna grab my hands.
Oh shit!
Oh, I just gotta punch it.
If all else fails, just punch your problems away.
Who would've thought?
All I had to do was punch.
I can't believe I...
I can't believe I forgot the most important lesson.
Just punch it.
No!
Oh my god, that's so sad.
The little guy.
I heard a crow.
Okay.
Let's see.
Yeah, I got the bridge over there.
And I'll grab these bridges too.
Can I climb up that?
Oh, okay, I can.
Nice.
Oh no, I can't.
Okay.
Um...
There's like something here too.
How do I get there?
Can I pull it?
I'm a strong... Oh, there it is.
Oh!
And we're stuck.
Oh, we're not.
I see that.
All right.
Let's go!
You think this can stop me?
I just push it through this?
I guess I do, right?
That's it!
Okay, I should push it here.
And then... Oh!
But then I heard there's something here though.
Oh, loot.
Loot!
Nice.
More money.
Maybe there's a way through that big gate up there?
Yes.
Arteus.
Yes, boy.
We go up.
And then we go up.
How do I get past this?
I can bash through any wood except for that wood door.
I don't understand.
What makes that wood door different from all the other wood doors?
Can I go through?
Oh!
Okay.
Never mind.
What could they be for?
There's something special.
Easy.
I can feel it.
There's something special?
Okay, we gotta get the fast pass here.
And then...
Wait, what was the lamp?
Oh, this lamp.
Okay.
How do I get there?
Oh!
Pull the door.
If I pull the door, do I pull it all the way?
How do I get over there?
On the...
Oh!
I pushed the box!
My brain is, like, working overtime right now.
How do I get over there?
What about there?
Oh!
Okay.
Light.
Oh!
Okay, that actually scared me.
There he is!
I see you!
I see you, government drone!
Okay, go, wolves, go!
Go, wolves, go!
Yay!
Okay.
I mean, I don't actually...
I don't actually need to get close to him.
Easy.
Oh, shit!
That's fucking right.
You're still easy!
That's right!
I don't take it back!
You're fucking easy!
Oh, I'm so sorry.
I'm so sorry.
I did not mean that.
All right.
Nice.
Okay, and then...
Fast pass?
Okay.
Oh.
They can do combos.
Let me fast pass!
Hello?
There's no more enemies!
Oh.
Never mind.
Okay.
That makes a lot more sense now.
I was like wondering why I couldn't do it.
All right.
Use your little arrows!
Use your little...
Oh, shit!
Use your little arrows!
There you go!
Nice.
Okay.
Fast pass.
Fast pass?
Ready Enwade!
Is there still more?
No.
I killed everything.
Fast pass.
Oh!
Okay.
Never mind.
There's still more.
Phew!
Look.
I could.
I would get closer, but like, why?
This is much more important.
Fast pass.
Nice, I did it!
Guys, you don't understand.
That was like way more important.
Oh, I stopped moving.
Sorry, I died of cringe, guys.
I was too absorbed with...
I was too absorbed with the...
with the fast pass.
Alright, loot.
Okay.
Where is... wait, what?
All the old stuff.
That was just one thing.
There's more old stuff?
Oh, there is.
Alright.
Nice.
Okay.
Up I go.
Oh, nice!
That's what I wanted.
Yay!
Your god's not real!
Alright.
Yay!
I think we have everything.
Uh...
Oh yeah, I gotta push this.
Oh!
Nope.
Gotta push!
Push, push, push!
Did I do it?
Is it here?
Up I go.
And then... jump!
I did it!
That's so easy!
I wonder if I can push it more.
Would it go anywhere if I...
Oh no, it doesn't.
Okay.
Alright.
Gotta go this way.
Where's the loot?
Oh, there it is!
The golden chest!
Okay, summon...
Wait!
What?
What is the bird?
Oh my god!
Wait a minute!
The birds are cooler!
Oh, the damage fucking sucks.
Nevermind.
Yeah, but it's one damage though!
Like, look at it!
It's one damage!
I don't know.
The damage is like one!
Okay, we'll try.
We're gonna try it.
We'll see how that goes.
I'll give it a shot.
I'll give it like two tries.
One is better than zero.
Yeah, but the wolf does three!
But the wolf does three damage though!
That's more than one!
Alright, up I go.
I wonder why RTS doesn't go like...
How does my dad...
I don't...
I feel like he'd be like, I don't think my dad's a human!
At that point.
When does he start...
When does he start doubting himself?
Okay.
When does he figure it out?
Uh...
I guess we have to...
We gotta go this way now.
You're the only...
Oh shit!
This is it!
I should have waited!
Guys, I should have waited.
I realize...
I realize I should have...
No, punch the other leg!
Why are you punching the left leg?
There's so many legs to punch!
Why are you punching the one leg that doesn't matter?
Okay.
I don't understand.
Please!
I sh...
There's so many legs!
Why are you not hitting the legs I want you to hit?
Oh shit, nice!
Got on the troll.
Stop hitting yourself!
That's right.
You might be...
Bad to me!
But you can't stop me!
It's not about the size!
Oh, okay.
We did it.
Okay, now use your crow.
Oh, shit!
Whoops.
Alright.
Oh!
Oh, god, I...
I got the duck in time.
Where the fuck did my axe go?!
Where did my axe go?!
Holy shit.
Bro, I know I'm almost dead!
That's why I need your help, boy!
Oh, no.
Please don't burn out.
Please.
Oh, god.
Oh, thank god.
Thank god, boy.
Boy, why did you aim that way?!
Fuck.
Please.
Oh, boy!
Why did you not aim that way?!
Holy shit, he could've aimed anywhere else.
Why the fuck did he aim that way?!
Wait, where did I kill the troll?!
Did he spawn?
Oh, there it is.
Oh, thank god.
That was actually 1 HP.
We can upgrade our fucking axe again.
It sends out a line of ice shards?
Ooh!
Wait, that's cool.
What is this?
The river of night.
Really increased the...
Ooh!
I wanna try that.
Alright, we're okay.
We're okay.
Alright.
Guys, I...
Guys.
I think after what we saw with the crows, we're gonna go with...
I think we're gonna go with the wolf after that.
I...
I think...
I think we realized...
Are you still fighting?
Okay, we gotta get rid of...
We gotta get rid of the crows.
God damn it!
Okay.
Apparently, he does not wanna use the wolves.
I don't know.
I'm still not convinced.
Yeah, that part where like, you know, the guy was right in front of him, but instead he decided to, you know, shoot everything but that.
Oh.
Am I supposed to...
What am I supposed to do?
What?
Oh.
Okay.
That's what I'm supposed to do.
Now what?
Oh.
Oh!
Alright.
Push, push, push, push, push.
Push, push, push.
Okay, boy, can I finally...
Okay, thank god.
Okay.
Alright.
No more...
No more brews for you.
There you go.
Up we go!
Okay.
Here we go!
Yay!
Do you think this goes all the way to the top?
Oh, fucking no, boy.
I'm like here at the same place as you are.
Like...
We are both experiencing the same thing together.
How am I supposed to know more than you?
We're literally here together.
Do not concern yourself with what might be.
Focus on what is.
And be vigilant.
Yes, sir.
Alright.
Not the top.
But we're closer.
Oh.
It took like forever to get there.
Holy shit.
That was really high.
Wait!
That one's not broken!
What is that?
Is that the lantern?
There's a note.
A giant's cry.
They're asking their ancestors to watch over them.
To guide them.
Well, they're all dead.
Boy.
Wait.
I think I know how it works.
Now you're into giant magic?
Oh?
Oh!
Watch.
That's like a little hot air balloon!
Oh!
That's cute.
What did you write?
I wish mom was here.
That's fucked man.
I thought that was a joke.
Oh, that's fire.
Okay.
I didn't worry about...
Loot, loot, loot.
Alright, let's see.
Toki, please.
Oh, go in there.
That's it.
I think that's gonna happen.
Tunnel boy.
Wait, he doesn't trust the boy to fucking time this?
Boy, are you fucking stupid?
What the fuck?
The boy should do this too!
That's not fair!
If I had to do it, the boy has to do it too.
Boy, go through this tunnel as well because apparently you're too stupid to time this.
Alright, let's see.
Is there anything I'm missing?
Alright.
Okay, apparently you can't fucking time this correctly.
Alright, nice.
How did you die over here?
Did you fall on your own sword or some shit?
This is like baby shit.
Why am I...
Oh, hey loot.
Whoa, what's that?
Goodbye.
Where?
That's one...
Wait, how did I get up there?
Wait, that's loot.
I don't wanna grab loot.
Get out.
Get out of my fucking lobby.
I'm trying to loot here.
Oh, this is how you get the loot.
Oh!
Where do I lock the mechanism?
Oh, I don't need to.
Alright.
Open chest.
Yay!
Steady armor favoring cooldown.
Do I have that?
Oh!
Okay, I'm willing to risk it.
Reduces all damage from dark elves.
Grants a blessing on any successful block.
Very low perk to grant gift when...
Oh!
I'll take my chances.
Alright, nice.
Okay.
Alright, hello boy.
Is there anything above me that I missed?
No, alright.
Alright boy, let's go!
This is stupid.
He should have done the trials with me.
It wasn't even that hard.
Woodoki is like, What is that supposed to mean?
Bye, Roth.
What do you mean with my luck?
Or not.
Are we still too hesitant?
Are we?
What are we missing?
Let's see.
Oh, chest!
Has it really been four hours?
Okay, this game has been really fun.
I don't know.
Did you die of cringe?
What happened to you?
What the fuck happened to you?
Why are you dehydrated?
Alright.
Oh,
rock.
Alright, goodbye rock.
Goodbye rock.
Up we go.
We should be up here now.
We're gonna see everything!
We will see when we get there.
Until then, eyes open.
Alright.
Am I gonna fight a god anytime soon?
I'm fine.
Just lost my balance for a moment.
You know, for someone so strong, you sure worry a lot.
It serves me well.
And how I keep us alive.
I guess.
Not a terribly fun way to live though.
What's that?
Oh shit!
Okay.
Oh my god.
Oh please!
R3, R3!
What do you mean?
I wasn't looking at anything.
Hahaha I don't know what you're talking about guys.
Hahaha I was just trying to look at my scenery.
Hehehehehe I was just looking at the mountains.
What the fuck are you talking about?
Hahaha
Look at that beautiful mountain behind me.
Oh shit!
Wait!
Oh, what?!
Fuck this, I'm going angry mode.
I'm angry!
That's right!
I'm so angry!
Oh shit, okay.
You know what, I'll take those.
Wait, how am I supposed to...
I'm too angry to fucking do rage attacks!
It's not fair!
Okay, nice.
And then...
Get outta here.
Get the fuck outta here.
Get the fuck... Oh!
Get outta here!
That's fucking right!
Get out of this lobby!
Man, angry.
How do we get out of here?
Here?
Oh.
I just pushed.
Push.
Push, man.
Alright.
Look at that.
Look at that hole.
Oh shit!
It's fine.
Everything is okay.
These guys are so fucking weak!
I don't need to upgrade anything with how weak you are!
That is HP.
Oh.
I took that back.
I'm so sorry.
I did not mean to...
I didn't mean to call you weak!
I'm so sorry!
Oh, please!
Use your wolves!
What's the point of having wolves if you can't use it?
Oh shit!
Where the fuck did you come from?
Oh, nice!
Execution time!
Alright.
That's right.
Doki smash!
Where am I?
That's fucking right.
Wait, you're still alive?
How?
What do you mean you're not ready?
Oh, hey.
Okay, I think he's dead.
Okay.
Alright.
You're actually babies.
Some more courage.
Steal.
Heal us.
We're stuck again?
Alright, time to push again.
Push.
Doki push.
Nice.
Are we there yet?
How fucking high is this mountain?
Just enjoying the view.
Yeah?
Wait, we're scattering?
We're doing all this to scatter her ashes?
I was not paying attention.
I thought this was important.
I...
I thought this was an important mission.
Oh, we made it!
Yippee!
Oh shit, is that a dragon?
What the fuck?
That's fucking right.
Oh!
Okay.
Whoops.
Oh fuck.
Oh!
It's okay.
I never learned my lesson.
Clearly.
Oh, I can block it.
Shoot the fucking hands!
What are you doing, boy?
Why are you shooting the head?
Hahaha.
Boy, please.
He's holding on to our fucking thing.
Alright.
Wait, he's breathing electricity.
That's not a real dragon.
What are you doing?
Be ready!
What the fuck is...
Bum bum.
What the fuck does he fly?
He has chicken wings for wings.
Bro, he doesn't even have wings.
That was intense.
Alright.
Alright, so...
Can we...
smash the crystal now?
Yeah.
Oh, can we do stuff with the crystal now?
I guess we can.
Did we finally learn?
No.
We didn't.
You can destroy it by combating shatter crystals with energy crystals.
Pull to pick up a shatter crystal.
And then...
Oh, is this the rock?
Oh!
Incredible!
Oh, this is how you do it.
I can't believe we fought a dragon.
I was aiming for his eyes, but I kept losing my footing.
Do you think this is their home?
Oh, you were aiming for the eyes.
Oh yeah, you're definitely the problem.
Boy, the air grows thin here.
No more questions.
Oh no.
Oh, yes.
I see.
Stop wasting our air, boy.
Alright.
We're not dying here.
What?
Who's Sindri?
Who the fuck is Sindri?
Sindri?
Is that you?
Oh!
The brother that doesn't...
Sorry.
He doesn't matter to me.
Oh, I forgot his name.
If he's not important, I just don't remember their name.
He's the corporal.
He works for CORPA, so I didn't bother to learn.
Bro, that dwarf's not even gonna fucking feed you.
He's like a pea.
He's like a fucking pea for your meal.
Not even gonna be worth it.
Boom, here I go.
He's like one singular pea.
He's on a diet.
Let's fucking go.
Oh shit, that looks so sick.
Get bored.
Oh, well obviously heavy attack.
Why the fuck would I ever do life?
Alright.
Bad dragon.
Oh, uh, uh.
Not a dragon.
Oh shit.
Oh fuck.
What's this weak spot?
I can't tell.
Wait, where do I go?
Oh, oh.
We're gonna play catch.
Open your mouth.
Nice.
Ow, not nice.
What the fuck?
Alright.
Oh.
Did I?
Yeah, okay, I got it right.
Okay.
That's fucking right.
Wait, how do I?
Where?
Oh, there!
Yeah!
Alright.
I made a hole.
Oh shit.
Okay, I gotta pick this up.
Oh, wait, ow!
That's not fair.
Okay, we're...
We're...
Oh, ow.
Okay, that's not fair as well.
The fuck do I?
Open your mouth!
God damn it!
Why don't you open your mouth?
I'm gonna fucking...
Shoot your...
Okay, nevermind.
I'm gonna hit your toes.
No toe hitting, I guess.
Oh, I can block stomps!
Okay.
Okay, nice.
I guess I'm just gonna...
I'm just gonna get your toes.
I guess, fuck your toes, I guess.
Oh?
Did I block that?
Alright, nice.
Wait, no?
That's not fair!
What?
Oh, it's the toes again!
Is it?
Is it just the toes?
Stupid toe...
Oh!
Guys, I can't tell.
I can't tell if it's the toes or not.
No, please!
Why do you have to block my own knees?
Oh, here we go.
Boy, please.
I'm just trying to grab this.
I'm just trying to grab it.
Please.
Okay, nice.
Got it.
I got it.
It's fine.
Might as well just do that.
Ow.
Okay, I need all the HP I can get.
Are you serious?
I totally fucking blocked that.
Fuck you.
Oh shit, I'm sorry.
I did not mean that.
I'm sorry.
I blocked that.
What are you talking about?
I totally blocked that.
This is bullshit.
Oh, come on!
Guys, I don't...
Oh.
Oh, no.
No, no, no!
No!
Oh my god.
Why is this dragon so buff?
Bro, fuck you and your claws.
Oh shit.
What?
Okay, I have to... I'm just gonna run.
I'm just gonna run.
Okay.
No!
This is... Is it not...
Dark Souls?
Is there no invisibility?
Oh, okay.
Stop.
Okay.
We're fine.
Does he use electricity now?
Okay, nice.
Alright.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no!
No!
Why is he on the fucking zap?
Fuck you!
There you go.
No, he's on it.
I can't do anything about it.
Fuck you.
Alright.
Nice.
Please!
Die!
Alright.
Okay, he's gone now.
Okay, he's not gone.
Yes, eat them!
Not me!
Be ready to lower the crane on my...
I don't know how this thing works!
I do not care!
Be ready!
Ow!
I fucked up.
Fuck this.
I'm gonna punch... I'm gonna punch your toes!
I don't care!
I'm gonna punch your toes!
Okay, guys.
Guys, I'm just... I should have not used that to punch you.
I should have not used that to punch you.
No!
Okay.
I'm learning!
I... I am attempting to learn!
Get down.
Get down, Mr. President!
Get down!
Ow!
Okay.
We're fine!
We're so fine!
Oh, here.
Oh, I can ride the dragon!
Oh,
I can ride the dragon!
That's fucking right!
Quick time, quick time, quick time!
Oh!
Oh, shit!
Oh,
shit!
And thus, all dragons are now extinct.
Oh, shit!
Watch the blood get absorbed into my skin.
And you!
But, but, but... Nobody's killed a dragon for hundreds of years!
Not since the grand culling of the worms.
And unless I'm mistaken, you did all that for me!
You are mistaken.
And the blood is gone now.
You deny it all you want.
But you saved me.
And that...
A free upgrade?
What are these?
Braided mistletoe arrows.
Straighter than Heimdall and perfectly weighted.
I thought they were celery, not gonna lie.
Have you seen my brother again?
Yeah.
He said you lost your talent.
Oh, and that I'm selfish?
No.
I'm sure.
That I value a weapon's look?
No.
Over its purpose.
That I'm pretentious?
No.
And I'm tight.
Fussy.
I know what he thinks, but he can't hurt me any...
Why the fuck do you have a fish?
Burn that.
I do not have time for this.
No, no, no, no, no.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
I have a better idea.
What?
I just need a tooth from that dragon.
I mean, he's dead.
Oh my god, think about all the weapons you can make out of this dragon.
What's the...
I can't believe it.
Father just killed a dragon.
I've never seen him fight like that before.
I mean, I know he's really strong and all, but that thing was huge.
I mean, he can't even fucking fly.
He had chicken wings.
Oh, that's his name?
Crazzler?
Alright.
I might as well be able to...
I should be able to farm this entire dragon.
I mean, this looks like a very old dragon.
Imagine all the equipment I can make out of this guy.
I should make my entire armor as dragon.
I've seen Monster Hunter.
This is like literally a whole new armor set.
Only one tooth?
This is fucking bullshit.
Angry.
Yeah.
I am not touching that.
Just hold it out.
Huh?
What?
Now, run that along the string of your son's bow.
Oh, he has the sap thing.
Atreus, your bow.
Give me your magic bow.
Two passes should do it.
Ah, gently now.
Oh.
Now I can destroy the red walls.
I have to like swap in between them?
Oh, sure.
Now you're impressed.
Nice.
How do I swap?
Oh, okay.
Oh.
I see.
Alright.
Let's see.
I should be able to...
Wait, no.
Upgrade my shit.
I have rare items.
Oh.
Okay.
Upgrade.
Alright.
And then...
I think it's...
I can upgrade his bow too.
Yeah.
Upgrade.
Okay.
Nice.
And then that's all I have to do.
No more.
That means I have...
skills now.
Right?
Uh...
Oh.
Shock duration.
Canal.
It's like greater amount.
Do I want shock?
Is shock better than light?
Okay, I'm gonna get these though.
It's like a stun.
Okay.
Oh.
It's situational.
Okay.
Alright, now I'm gonna focus on me.
That's enough for me to know.
I'm gonna focus on me.
On the second...
Uh...
While barehanded, aim and press to instantly recall and perform... Oh!
Okay.
I don't know, honestly.
It is objectively better?
Okay, then I guess I'll...
I'll try it out.
I'll upgrade some shock just in case.
Alright.
Alright, boy.
I'm gonna test your shock skills out.
Now we fought dark elves.
Oh!
I feel like we could be anything.
We win because we are determined.
Disciplined.
Not because we feel ourselves superior.
Sure.
Light runic.
What's that?
Oh!
Wait.
No, that doesn't...
That doesn't matter.
At one, that's four damage.
And two stun.
Alright, up we go, boy.
I wanna test out your shock.
I don't know what the shock is like.
Up we go.
I can't believe it, guys.
Now, we're at 10% of the story.
Oh, what?
Oh, shit!
Oh!
Okay, light...
Wait, what?
What the fuck?
What the?
Oh!
That was crazy.
What the fuck?
Yeah, he regen super fast.
And make them stronger.
Wait, what?
Yeah, that shit went so fast.
I don't even know how the fuck to...
I had to like...
I had to like fucking, uh...
Wait, what?
Yeah.
Oh!
Okay, up we go.
Alright.
It's time to shoot.
Oh, nice.
Okay.
I want to test your shock skills out.
Alright.
Do it again!
Do it again, boy!
Alright.
It's not so bad.
The shock is not that bad.
The stun is really good.
Okay, so stun a possessed enemy.
Okay.
I just need to stun it and then...
Uh...
And then...
And then I should kill it.
I just won by brute forcing.
Oh!
Nice.
Alright.
No, no, no, no, no.
You're not getting...
No!
God damn it.
It's fine.
Oh, what?
Oh shit, I forgot!
I forgot this shit doesn't...
I have to use my arms.
I forgot what that was like.
I forgot what it was like to use my arms.
I haven't done that in so long.
Alright.
Let's see.
I got all my HP back though.
What's this?
So...
Oh my god.
There's so many buttons to pay attention to now.
I'm getting a little bit overwhelmed.
I'm going to forget all these moves.
100% chat.
Let me see.
What?
Wait.
Get to this area though.
I guess it's on the other side?
Doesn't matter.
Wait, what the fuck?
Can I stun him?
Okay.
Okay, nice.
Oh, I can't block that.
What the fuck happened?
Okay.
Maybe I shouldn't have interrupted their prayer session.
Okay, but what if?
Oh shit.
I'm sorry.
It was a joke.
Okay, but what if though?
It's fine.
What is he going to do?
Kill me?
It's fine.
If I don't touch him, he can't kill me.
See?
Oh, I have the wolves.
The wolves are so strong.
Oh my god.
Look how strong it is.
Okay.
We got this.
See?
Easy.
I told you.
Oh no.
I'm sorry.
Easy.
See?
I told you guys.
So easy.
What?
I thought I heard something.
Okay.
Oh.
That breaks this, right?
Yes.
Oh, it was all for lore?
I think I was too young.
Are giants coming out of his armpits?
What?
What the fuck?
I think it might be Odin stabbing him.
What the?
Try this, Liv.
What?
What is this story?
What the?
What's that?
Okay, I need to know this story.
Why is there maggots?
Okay.
Alright, we found one of it.
Alright.
That's a fetish right there.
Okay.
Missing two more.
Where's the last two?
That's a wild story.
Yeah, I was like, what the fuck?
Where's the last two?
Okay, so we got one of the shrines there.
We're literally missing one, two more.
Where do I go?
Do I hit that?
Oh!
Phew!
Is that it?
And then...
Phew!
I did it!
I will never get tired of shattering things with this.
You're so smart!
Oh god, no!
Oh no!
It's okay, I'm stronger!
Oh, where's my axe?
You can't regen if I'm stronger!
That's fucking right!
Nice.
Oh my god, another one?
That takes care of that.
And then...
We gotta grab another...
You gotta grab another one.
Alright, here we go.
And...
Oh, there's...
There it is!
Yeah.
Let me grab that too.
Reading!
Oh shit, not reading!
Get down!
Gotta swat some mosquitoes.
What?
Why did I hear...
I heard something.
Oh well.
Read.
Where's the last shrine?
Interesting.
Yeah, what does it say?
Okay.
Don't talk to your father, I guess.
Alright, that was too long.
You're right, maybe.
You made a good choice not teaching me what that said.
Alright.
Maybe the shrine's here?
Okay, there is a chest.
He's not dead!
Get out of here!
That's fucking right.
Give me that loot.
Alright.
And...
Phew!
Okay, now how do I get back?
Oh!
I just jump.
Nice.
And then the chest is open.
Yay!
More HP!
Yeah.
Okay.
Uh...
Guess we go this way.
Please let me out of this cave.
Please, I just want to spread my dead white ashes.
Please.
That's all I want.
I've been trying to climb up this fucking mountain for 20 years.
Fucking finally!
Am I at the top?
Please!
How far am I to the summit?
Your quiver.
Strap broke when we fought the dragon.
It's alright.
I finally made it!
I swear to god, if a fucking another dragon comes over and knocks the only pathway to the summit, I swear to fucking god.
I so- Broken quiver will slow your draw.
Pain we endure.
Faulty weaponry we do not.
This will do for now.
Good?
I swear to god.
We're so close.
I just want to spread dead ashes.
I killed a million people today.
And I just want to fucking spread my dead white ashes.
That's all I want.
And also beat up some jars.
But other than that, that's literally all I want.
Alright.
Go through.
You first, boy!
Boy, you first!
Alright!
Wow!
Look at this long ass fucking- Wow!
I wonder what's gonna happen in this long fucking corridor.
Alright, get down.
Alright, nice.
Oh man!
I wonder what's gonna fucking happen!
Oh wait, is this a- Okay, yeah.
Alright, give me a sec.
I gotta beat you up with my hands.
I keep forgetting what that is like.
Alright.
Off we go.
We're getting so close.
We're getting so close to the end!
We're getting so close to spreading my wife's ashes!
Alright, here we go.
We're at the final stretch!
Wouldn't it be funny if it collapses?
Where's the door?
Hidden man?
Wife, who is this hidden man?
Dead wife.
Why did you- Were you trying to tell me there was another man?
What do you mean hidden man?
You hear those voices too, right?
Yes.
Be silent.
What do you mean?
Who is this hidden man?
That sounds like the same man who came to our house.
You said you killed him.
Wait, what?
It must be important that the sons of Thor deign to grace me with their presence.
Tell me.
You two still tripping over yourselves to Is he a tree?
The tattooed man tracks show he now travels with a child.
Where would they go next?
Why would I know that?
You the smartest man alive, aren't you?
There's three men?
You help me, I help you.
Tell me where they are, and I'll talk to Odin.
Your father won't let me go bald out and he won't let you kill me.
You have nothing to offer me, so take the question.
Take these two worthless wankers and piss off.
Damn.
When no one's looking.
I thought this was Norse.
Why is he British?
Don't you forget.
Why is he Scottish?
Oh, Balder!
Okay.
How is Balder over there?
Alright.
We go down.
And up we go.
Up we go.
Please.
The moment I spread these ashes, I'm fucking ending stream for today.
Whoa!
Very topic of conversation.
A tattooed man traveling with a child.
Boy took their path.
Make sure we're all alone.
But we just saw them leave.
Do as I say.
He doesn't know what you are.
And I would keep it that way.
Who are you?
Me?
I'm the greatest ambassador to the gods, the giants, and all the creatures of the nine realms.
I know every corner of these lands, every language spoken, every war waged, every deal struck.
They call me Mimir!
Mimir?
And I have the answer to every question.
Why does the son of Odin haunt us?
Okay, there are a few gaps in my knowledge.
But Odin's had me imprisoned here for 109 years.
I'm the smartest man alive, but like 109 years ago.
I'll piece it together.
I promise.
Given time.
So like what happened in the last 109 years?
Just like I said.
The boy's mother is dead.
She wanted us to spread her ashes on the highest peak in all the realms.
Is this not the highest peak?
Are you fucking kidding me?
It's in Yot-9.
Why did you say that?
No!
This is not the highest peak!
Are you fucking kidding me?
Why did I have to ask him that?
Looks like a giant's fingers scrape in the sky.
That's the highest peak in all the realms.
Maybe she went the highest peak in Midgard.
When the giants destroyed all other bridges to their realm, they locked this one up with a secret rune.
If it still exists, only a giant would know it.
Princess, the peak is at another castle.
Boy, why did you ask that?
Why?
It's a vortex of coincidence.
It is.
There's only one person alive who can get you where you need to go.
And luckily for you, my schedule's wide open.
Spread the ashes.
She's dead.
She doesn't fucking care.
She's already dead.
She won't know.
This is just symbolic.
We can just pretend this is the highest peak.
Wait, what?
She'll never know!
Not even Thor's hammer could free my body from these bonds.
But fortunately, you don't need my body.
The trick is, we need to find someone who can reanimate my head using the old magic.
Am I cutting his head off?
Here's a witch of the woods.
She knows the old ways.
And she'll help.
She might do worth a try.
But if she fails, he will be dead.
He tortures me, you know.
What?
Every day, brother.
Wouldn't himself cease to hate personally and believe me?
There is no end to his creativity.
Every single day.
Oh, that's fucked.
This.
This isn't living.
Damn.
Oh, I can't watch this.
Oh!
He's gonna meme her forever.
In case she can't resurrect me, there's something you need to know.
Boy.
The longer you wait to tell him his true nature, the more damage you do.
He will resent you and you may lose him forever.
Okay.
He fucking threw...
He fucking killed a dragon.
He's not a normal human being.
Your son knows.
There's no way.
He literally
watched me fucking destroy a dragon.
How does he not know?
How the fuck does he not know?
I don't know.
Fucking push the giant ass How do you not know, boy?
Have you never seen another man before?
Are you...
Oh my god.
Why?
Why did you have to...
Why can't you lie?
Why?
I don't understand.
Why can't you lie to this boy and be like this is the highest peak in the world.
That's all you had to do.
That's literally all you had to do.
I killed so many people to just be up here.
Boy was homeschooled and has some knowledge.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I don't understand.
I thought I could spread my ashes.
Oh there it is.
That's where we killed her fucking best friend.
Does he think all men can fucking do that?
Oh okay.
We updated the map.
Oh is this the fast pass?
Alright.
Where do we have to go?
Here.
Jesus Christ.
Okay.
We're calling in here.
I don't fucking care.
I'm calling in here.
I can't.
I can't keep going.
I'm done.
I don't care.
We don't get to spread my dead wife's ashes.
I'm fucking tired.
I remember I was like I'm just gonna play for it.
I'm gonna play for a little bit.
I'm not gonna do too darn today.
Oh it's fun.
I had a lot of fun playing it today.
At least I climbed the highest mountain in Midgard.
She didn't even specify.
All she wanted was the highest point.
She never specified what kind of highest.
That's the thing.
Why does the boy have to be so fucking precise?
She was like I just want me to spread to the highest peak.
She never said exactly be like highest peak of all.
She said all the realms.
That fucking bitch.
God.
You're dead.
You should not be making any demands.
You're fucking dead.
So demanding.
Even in the afterlife she's so fucking demanding.
Oh my god.
Anyway.
It's only 25 hours to beat the game.
Just 20 more hours to go.
We can do it.
Thank you.
I'm gonna call it here everybody.
Yes she's dead.
Why is she making demands on me?
She'll never know.
What's she gonna do?
Haunt me?
Too bad I'm a fucking Yeah haunt me?
Too bad I'm a fucking god of war.
I killed my first wife and my daughter.
You haunting me is not gonna do much.
I'm already haunted.
You can't make it even more haunted.
I'm already cursed.
You can't double curse me.
I've already maxed out my trauma.
Like...
Like oh but then when you die you gotta deal with her.
I can't die.
I'm a fucking god.
I live forever.
It doesn't matter.
Alright.
I'm gonna call it here everybody.
I had a great time playing it though.
It is definitely a really... I've been enjoying this game a lot.
Honestly.
So time really does pass by super fast when playing this game and I've definitely been enjoying it a lot.
It took a while for my brain to get started.
I was just saying random shit as I went along.
My brain was like... was like a fucking like... like you're trying to rev up the car and it's like... it's like locked out.
It's just like...
It's like not starting.
That was my brain today.
But the longer we went the further we got.
Anyway guys.
I'm gonna call it here as always everybody.
Stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get up and move around.
Get that blood flowing and except for me head to bed cause you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time everybody.
Bye guys.
Bye.
Where's the ending screen?
Oh there it is.
Bye.